bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est heureux de vous
retrouver pour faire pour faire vivre
cette soirée électorale après une
campagne hors normes dans un instant en
direction les quartiers généraux de
plusieurs candidats un chiffre déjà
celui de l'abstention selon en tous les
cas l'ifop c'est une estimation
24% on va le commenter avec nos invités
en plateau bien évidemment on va aller
aussi dans les coulisses du figaro au
coeur de la newsroom avec bruno drye
juste après le générique
[Musique]
bonsoir vincent et bonsoir à vous tous
les internautes qui nous suivaient sur
le figaro je suis ravi d'être avec vous
pour ce premier soir de l'élection
présidentielle alors je me trouve en
plein milieu de la rédaction du
figaro.fr au coeur de la newsroom comme
on dit et j'ai rendez vous tout de suite
avec jim jarrassé donc rédacteur en chef
adjoint du service politique du figaro
venez avec moi je vais vous demander de
me suivre sur les images donc de maxime
laurie on se dirige vers le service
politique du figaro vivent assez bon
soir
alors c'est un soir crucial pour le
service politique et pour tous le figaro
comment vous êtes préparé ça fait
environ une semaine donc on se prépare
avec le service politique du figaro on
travaille avec différents services
évidemment la rédaction web que vous
allez allez voir dans quelques minutes
je crois les services techniques du
journal donc les secrétaires de
rédaction la direction artistique avec
lesquels on a préparé la maquette du
journal que vous allez voir également
dans quelques donc quelques minutes ses
treize pages de
d'articles sur cette première soirée
électorale du premier tour la
présidentielle et puis évidemment avec
le service politique qui est juste là
justement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu votre équipe
maxime laurie je vous demande de vous
retourner vers le service politique
combien de journalistes ont mobilisé ce
soir évidemment tout le monde est sur le
pont on a quinze journalistes qui sont
mobilisés on a ce qu'on appelle les
rubricards qui sont les journées ce qui
suivent un parti politique en
particulier des déjà depuis des années
et qui maintenant depuis plusieurs mois
suivent un candidat en particulier ils
sont allés sur le terrain pendant
pendant des mois pendant pour un peu
ressentir quelle était l'ambiance et la
dynamique des candidats qui suivait donc
ils sont mobilisés ce soir pour donner
un peu l'analyse des résultats sur leur
candidat et puis on a un pool de
journalistes
un peu plus polyvalent qui va être
chargé de d'être le plus réactif
possible pour réaliser des articles pour
le web et donner du coup vraiment le
ressenti en temps réel de cette de cette
soirée électorale et puis il faut quand
même aussi ajouter qu on a quinze
journalistes qui sont mobilisés sur le
terrain dans les qg des candidats
là aussi pour à la fois pour le web et
pour le print nous retranscrit un peu
l'ambiance sur le terrain puisque c'est
aussi important d'avoir un peu de de
chair humaine de pâte humaine pour voir
comment est bien dans telles ou telles
qg on prend on prend les scores qui vont
être annoncées à 20 heures dernière
question d'image arras et qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir trouver dans le journal
dans le figaro de demain alors demain
vous allez pouvoir retrouver 13 pages
qui vont ouvrir donc le journal 13 pages
consacrées à cette à ce premier tour de
la présidentielle on commence le journal
par une double page un peu globale pour
analyser dans leur intégralité les
résultats et puis parlait aussi d'une
donnée importante qui est la donnée de
l'abstention qui est relativement qu'on
annonce relativement élevé ce soir et
puis ensuite on déclinera candidat par
candidat en commençant évidemment par
les deux qualifiés au second tour qui
auront droit à deux passes chacun eh ben
les analyses les reportages sur le
terrain peut-être aussi commencé à se
projeter sur l'entre-deux tours qui va
être crucial pour pour tous les
candidats et puis des infographies
d'ailleurs on terminera le journal en
tout cas la partie politique par une
grande carte de france des résultats par
commune qui permettra d'avoir un peu le
le tableau global de 7 de cette soirée
du premier tour la présidentielle merci
d'une jarrassé je vous laisse regagner
votre bureau et puis ne manquez pas aux
alentours de minuit vous pourrez
découvrir en direct sur figaro live donc
la une de votre journal de demain c'est
alexis braisé patron des rédactions qui
viendra vous la présenter depuis le
studio haussmann avoue vincent roux et
voilà et on est dans le fameux studio
haussmann du figaro merci beaucoup brune
le premier chiffre dont on dispose gym
il faisait allusion tout à l'heure c'est
une estimation une estimation de l'ifop
un taux d'abstention de 24% on en débat
ce soir avec les premiers intervenants
les premiers contributeurs sur ce
plateau bonsoir céline bracq bon sens
vincent coprésident des instituts aux
docks ça à côté de vous yves thréard
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro et présentateurs des treize
numéros du club le figaro présidentielle
qu'on a eu le plaisir auquel on a eu le
plaisir d'assister depuis le mois de
janvier ça continue d'ailleurs après ce
premier toit guillaume roquette
également directeur de la rédaction du
figaro magazine bonsoir guillaume et
anne fulda grand reporter au figaro
bonsoir à ça et auteur de la première
biographie politique des manuels ce
n'est pas la première mais
medalist est paru bons noms sont apparus
ça a compté stablement c'était la
meilleure enfin c'était là la première
qu'ils avaient rentré dans la
psychologie des manuels de macron et ça
sera intéressant justement de savoir
d'autres un peu dans la tête du
président candidat ce soir avant d'avoir
ces résultats 1re j'aimerais bien avoir
d'abord un premier commentaire de votre
de votre part peut-être je commence avec
vous céline sur ces chiffres de
l'abstention est ce que d'abord est-ce
que chez aux docks ça ce sont les mêmes
chiffres les mêmes estimations et
question subsidiaire est ce que on sait
qui s'est abstenu alors la première
question est ce qu'on est on est à peu
près à ses proches de l'ifop notre
estimation à nous de l'abstention chez
eux doxa elle est de 27% par rapport aux
données qu'on a pu récupérer sur le
terrain aujourd'hui et les calculs par
rapport à l'abstention à 17h projeté à
20 heures on serait à 27% c'est à dire
que on serait sûr à l'abstention très
haute pour une présidentielle mais qui
ne dépasserait pas le record de 2002 le
record de 2002 c'était 28 4% pour être
précis on retrouverait la structure
habituelle des abstentionnistes c'est à
dire en particulier
des jeunes des plus tôt des électeurs de
gauche et des catégories sociales qu'on
appelle les csp moi c'est à dire plus
les employés plus les ouvriers qui
auraient moins voté que les autres
catégories donc a priori c'est ce que
l'on retrouve encore une fois dans cette
élection avec un niveau d'abstention un
peu plus élevé encore que celui qu'on
avait observé lors de la dernière
présidentielle un premier commentaire
une première analyse
écoutez c'est plutôt mieux que ce qu'on
nous avait annoncé puisque pendant ces
semaines et espère que disait marcel
après c'est juste exactement on serait
dans la plaque par rapport à ce qu'ont
avancé jet faudra aux dogues savent pour
le figaro à jouer comme ça si tel est le
cas
on va dire qu'une grande majorité des
institutions d'art je disais prévoyez un
taux d'abstention important plus elle
vient de l'ordre de 30 % c'est-à-dire
plus élevé encore qu'en 2002 donc on
était très inquiet sur l'état de notre
démocratie sur l'état de santé de notre
de l'opinion publique en france aussi on
est à 1 28% moi je crois que tu vas dire
que cette histoire de d'abstention j'en
suis assez assez persuadé c'est pas
structurel je pense que c'est
conjoncturel oui regardez en 2002 il ya
eu une abstention importante qui est de
l'ordre de 28% et en 2007 on n'a jamais
autant voter parce qu'il y avait une
offre qui était intéressante qui a
passionné les français avec une
présidentielle cas probablement
d'ailleurs de mon point de vue
d'ailleurs était une des meilleures de
la vème république
lundi là on avait un problème d'offre
aussi dans cet euro pas se le cacher il
y avait une offre qui était quand même
relativement
médiocre d'une part deuxièmement avec un
président sortant candidat et tous les
commentateurs le savent dès qu'il ya un
sortant c'est moins bien c'est moins
bien parce qu'il n'y a pas eu ce côté
renouvellement qui appelle justement à
rafraîchir un peu le un peu l'offre et
des têtes ça c'est la chose que je
voudrais souligner je crois pas que les
français et d'ailleurs ils sont en train
de le démentir isp ils sont pas des
intéressés par la politique c'est
simplement que peut-être que l'offre qui
leur a été donnée n'était pas celle qui
le il les a passionnés ressentiment oui
je pense qu'il ne faut pas oublier le
contexte dans laquelle se situe aussi
cette élection c'est à dire que on sort
quand même d'une
d'une période très étrange avec on a eu
on a vécu un confinement une crise
sanitaire qui n'est pas complètement
terminée qui a quand même beaucoup
marqué ya une espèce de de fatigue qui a
touché tout le monde en fait y compris
dans le dans l'implication politique
plus le contexte international
évidemment qui a joué et un président
sortant qui effectivement
n'était pas n'était pas dans la
nouveauté mais c'est surtout parce qu'il
était très très captée par par la
situation internationale parce que
président parce que président de l'union
européenne et parce que aussi on a eu
l'impression parfois enfin qu'il était
peut-être
plus plus concernés par une espèce de
bras de fer avec vladimir poutine
que de par le lit sud la campagne
présidentielle
guillaume vous avez appelé vos lecteurs
à voter dans votre éditorial de ce week
end apparemment vous avez vous allaitez
quand même un peu entendu oui je crois
d'ailleurs que j'ai une responsabilité
éminente dans ce qui se passe on n'en
doute pas un seul instant je pense que
c'est une relativement bonne nouvelle
même si le niveau d'abstention est quand
même relativement élevés en valeur
absolue d'abord sur l'esprit civique des
français et ensuite pour ce qui
s'annonce pour le vainqueur quel qu'il
soit de cette élection on a beaucoup dit
que la campagne avait pas eu lieu parce
que effectivement le président de la
république étaient occupés par d'autres
affaires parce qu'il n'ya pas eu de
débat au sens classique du terme à la
télévision entre les différents
candidats et le candidat sortant et donc
on avait une petite musique sur le thème
c'est l'élection qui n'aura pas lieu et
ben non ça n'est pas le cas les français
sont allés voter juste je rajoute un mot
pour dire et je n'ai aucun moyen de le
prouver que je n'ai pas la même
intuition qu'yves moi je pense que
l'abstention elle est structurelle elle
correspond à l'évolution de la société
qui est de plus en plus individualiste
et donc des gens qui sont moins
concernés et j'ai juste un tout petit
élément à la bhl là là pour conforter sa
c'est que c'est surtout les jeunes qui
s'abstiennent en or a priori les jeunes
ils vont voter plus longtemps que les
vieux alors on va débattre de cela dans
une deuxième partie je vous propose
d'entamer une nouvelle séquence c'est
d'aller justement dans les quartiers
généraux est également retourné sur la
newsroom du figaro j'en profite pour
saluer les internautes qui nous
rejoignent à mk qui nous dit que c'est
un plaisir de suivre cette élection avec
nous et bien c'est également un plaisir
d'abord de vous lire et également de
suivre cette élection avec vous bonsoir
claudius bonsoir marcelo bonsoir
l'entarteur bonsoir frédéric vous
continuez à commenter à réagir vous nous
posez vos questions vous réagissez déjà
donc par rapport à ce chiffre de 24 %
qui sont les estimations d'ifop on est
dans des estimations à ses voisines aux
alentours de 27 % avec aux docks ça on
va continuer à suivre et à commenter
dans ces trois quarts d'heure avant les
résultats avant les premières
estimations plus exactement ce chiffre
de l'abstention mais je voudrais d'abord
qu'on aille au parc des expositions
porte porte de versailles
retrouvez vincent heureusement au
quartier général des manuels macron
vincent quelle est l'ambiance
bonjour vincent et bien effectivement
l'ambiance actuellement est assez calme
les gens arrivent petit à petit vous
pouvez voir derrière moi on distribue
les drapeaux on distribue des petits
t-shirt drapeaux français et européen ou
d'autres avec l'agglo part donc avec le
slogan des manuels macron on va se
déplacer on va vous montrer maintenant
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté de la
scène parce que là pour l'instant nous
sommes sur l'entrée les gens arrivent
petit à petit et on va vous montrer le
podium où bientôt emmanuel macron va va
parler dans quelques instants pendant
quelques instants pardon ebe paradis si
une heure après les
après les différentes après les
résultats comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images de renault et de baise qui
était avec moi on va essayer de trouver
un petit endroit où on pourra bien vous
montrer voilà ça c'est l'endroit d'où
emmanuel bach on va parler à côté
ici vous voyez les drapeaux le slogan
nous tous et de l'autre côté l'autre
chose très importante c'est le nom de
joyeuses présent énormément de gens
disent qu'ils sont présents aujourd'hui
notamment internationaux qui sont fait
accréditer pour suivre ce cette soirée
électorale au qg des manuels macro et
soirées qu'on va suivre avec vous merci
beaucoup vincent merci pour ces premiers
éléments donc si je vous suis emmanuel
macron devrait s'exprimer
pas peu après l'annoncé des premières
estimations
dans quel état d'esprit se trouve
quelqu'un comme emmanuel macron vous qui
avez étudié sa psychologie de pré mâchée
ran écoutez je pense qu'il est un peu
comme nous tous il attend les résultats
bon je pense qu'
il s' est probable il ne serait
probablement pas départi d'une forme de
certitude qu'il serait au deuxième tour
même si c'était pas si évident que ça
enfin et la manière dont il a mené
campagne
l'un peut prouver sa la façon dont il a
fait campagne a beaucoup fait penser à
celle de giscard c'est à dire qu'il
devait convaincu enfin il était
convaincu que de toute façon il serait
présent au deuxième tour et que
finalement il n'aura pas à faire une
vraie campagne ce qu'on va trouver on ne
sait rien encore on verra un famille
portait en tout cas il a mené campagne
en donnant cette impression là enfin
outre le contexte international qui ont
évoqué tout à l'heure je pense que cet
élément a joué aussi il semblait assurée
d'avoir de toute façon une certaine
avance je salue notre confrère emmanuel
razavi qui nous suit depuis barcelone
allemagne razali qui dirige le pure
player field qu'on recommande est que
pure player de référence sur l'actualité
internationale
on va retourner au coeur de la
news from du figaro on va retrouver
brume d'audrey qui se trouve avec
frédéric picard le rédacteur en chef qui
figureront pourrait faire
mais je vous présente maintenant
frédéric picard bonsoir frédéric picard
rédacteur en chef au figaro notamment en
charge des tranches du soir sur
lefigaro.fr c'est votre deuxième soirée
présidentielle dans ce fauteuil ici
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
comment ces soirées six spéciales ont
évolué au fil du temps au figaro déjà ça
a beaucoup évolué par rapport à la
dernière donc la dernière élection
présidentielle
cette fois ci il ya encore une grande
osmose ya une grande se pose maintenant
entre le print et web c'est-à-dire qu'on
le site bénéficie de l'expertisé de
l'excellence de nos journalistes du
service politique et dans au desk on
arrive à récupérer toutes ces
informations et a alimenté au le plus
rapidement le live est ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter un petit peu
l'équipe qui est des revers est derrière
vous et nous expliquer comment ça va se
passer ce soir et bien alors ce soir la
particularité c'est d'être le plus
réactif possible d'informer au mieux nos
internautes
pour ce faire nous avons une vingtaine
de collaborateurs qui sont dans les
différents qg ses informations remontent
sur ce plateau là qu'il y a juste sur
sur votre droite ou alors à kolin steve
remonte les informations pour aller
monter le live bien évidemment comme
nous n'avons pas que ça ce soir amaury
et d'autres collaborateurs travaillent
sur le reste de l'actualité parce qu'il
faut informer aussi sur le reste de
l'actualité et pour orchestrer tout ça
nous avons rassemblé au derrière moi et
avec moi mais je dire pour être le chef
d'orchestre de ce qui se passe on va
dire les meilleurs violon c'est à dire
que sur le premium sert tous les papiers
vous avez vu avec tim tout à l'heure
tous les papiers qui remonte du prime
c'est l'équipe de samuel potier de
sylvère qui vont nous dire au fur et à
mesure qu'elles sont les papiers qu'ils
doivent être payant et ceux qui doivent
être gratuits ce que l'on peut pousser
pour diverses raisons sur la houillère
pouchet c'est-à-dire mise en avant
auprès de notre de nos internautes un
pouce c'est ce qu'on reçoit sur notre
application mobile voilà absolument nous
avons nous travaillons aussi évidemment
beaucoup pendant cette soirée avec les
réseaux sociaux avec l'équipe d'audience
2 et tc lignan qui nous dit exactement
comment se comporte notre langue et nos
papiers sur sur les différents réseaux
savoir ce qu'on doit changer comment on
doit le changer pour être le plus proche
des attentes de nos internautes nous
avons nous travaillons bien évidemment
avec la vidéo c'est à dire que tout au
long de la soirée en tête de home nous
allons avoir les différentes
interventions des différentes analyses
de nos collègues qui sont avec vous en
plateau et ceux qui sont sur le terrain
et les déclarations des candidats est
évidemment les déclarations des
candidats qu'on mettra qu'on n'oubliera
pas de m nous travaillons aussi beaucoup
avec la data le staff et de stéphane
saunier de façon à donner des chiffres
parce que c'est une soirée deux chiffres
et tout ça on arrive à le coordonner
parce que je travaille avec damien
duperey et étienne jacob qui sont aussi
mes yeux et mes oreilles et ce soir du
coup à minuit on remballe tout est
éteint comment ça se passe donc pas
exactement à minuit justement on passe
la main à notre staff qui se trouve en
californie qui travaillent en californie
et qui est chapeauté par valérie samson
et à 5 heures du matin bien c'est
l'équipe de mario joseph qui reprend la
main et qui va débuter une nouvelle
journée avec les commentaires les
analyses de ce qui se passe ce soir
je vous laisse à votre poste quant à moi
je vous retrouve dans quelques instants
avec le service réseaux sociaux cette
fois ci et en attendant de vous
retrouver également sur ce plateau
hochart brune merci beaucoup à tout à
l'heure je réponds à certains
internautes qui donnent des estimations
en ce moment deux sites étrangers ce
qu'on peut vous dire c'est que ces
chiffres ne sont pas forcément
du tout des références dans la mesure où
les deux choses c'est que les bureaux de
vote ne sont pas faire dons viennent de
fermer et donc c'est en ce moment par
les sondages pouvoir avoir des résultats
du des résultats d'une élection il faut
une estimation s'il ya quelque chose de
particulier sont pas des gens qu'on
interroge mais ce sont des bulletins que
l'on tire et seuls les estimations sont
fiables pour les résultats lorsque vous
voyez circuler en ce moment ce sont des
sondages du jour du vote où on interroge
des gens mais qui ne sont pas très
solides c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
en matière de résultats voilà on a
répondu donc à galite on rappelle
également que vous êtes les bienvenus
pour commenter cette soirée électorale
sur le chat du figaro mais également
dans les limites du respect des pour les
personnes qui interviennent et également
entre vous dans le débat et nous
n'hésiterons pas à bannir si des propos
inconvenants sont tenus merci beaucoup à
tous les cas de nous suivre on va aller
tout de suite au parc floral de
vincennes retrouver daphné caravaca qui
se trouve donc au coeur de la soirée
électorale de marine le pen
oui bonsoir vincent alors ici c'est
l'effervescence tout le monde court dans
tous les sens mais pour l'heure il ya
autant de journalistes que d'invités
comme vous le disiez nous sommes en
plein coeur du bois de vincennes c'est
le même lieu qu'avait choisi marine le
pen en 2017 pour la soirée électorale du
second tour cette soirée déterminante
pour les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle se déroule ici plutôt
dans la bonne humeur les invités sont
confiants marine le pen sera au second
tour ça ne fait aucun doute ici les
invités sont des personnes méritantes je
cite comme l'organisation l'organisation
pardon nous l'a indiqué du champagne et
du vin sont d'ailleurs déjà au rendez
vous dans cette salle de réception du
12e arrondissement
nous verrons ce qu'il en est tout à leur
avantage
merci beaucoup effectivement daphné pour
l'instant il n'y a pas encore
d'estimations fiables qui sont parvenus
la posture d'un rassemblement national
confiant c'est quelque chose c'est un
classique de soirée présidentialise oui
c'est un classique bon ils ont ils ont
raté des paires des présidentielles ne
faut pas l'oublier en 2007 précisément
d'en parler tout à l'heure il avait fait
10 % puisqu'il avait sacré 2206 a été
aspirée vers ivg et c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce que en 2002 on pensait
peut-être que c'était début de lancement
et de l'installation du parti bon depuis
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les ponts
beaucoup de choses ont changé
notamment je dirais dans la vitrine
jusque dans le fond et marine le pen ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est de voir
que marine le pen effectivement et est
donné comme l'un des favoris de ce
scrutin alors que si vous vous rappelez
il ya huit mois ce qu'on disait avec
l'entrée dans l'atmosphère de
eric zemmour on pensait vraiment qu'eric
zemmour allait considérablement perturbé
sa campagne électorale elle l'a perturbé
sa campagne en attente parce que d'abord
elle a perdu 10 points dans les sondages
en quelques quelques jours premièrement
et deuxièmement elle s'est mis entre
parenthèses quasiment de la campagne
parce qu'elle savait pas du tout comment
négocier cet affront finalement et elle
est revenue sans changer de discours
avec exactement la même je dirais
posture qu'avant parce qu'elle avait
décidé d'avoir une posture beaucoup plus
en pâtit moins ouvertes sur le thème de
la liberté
sa vie privée c'est chad elle n'a pas
changé elle apparaît dit son discours
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer pour justement et éviter ou
étrangler plutôt le eric zemmour qui la
concurrence et je trouve comme on verra
on verra les résultats mais moi ce qui
est ce que j'ai trouvé frappant c'est le
la similitude avec le positionnement et
la campagne de jacques chirac 95 jacques
chirac que qu'on disait après
l'apparition de balladur on peut dire
que zemmour a été un peu le bal est dur
de marine le pen on a eu fini on l'a dit
non mais on a eu on avait dit qu'il
était qu'il était foutu enfin qu'il
était mort on leur présentait aux
guignols avec des couteaux dans le dos
donc il ya ça y est l'autre point c'est
la troisième fois qu'elle se présente
il ya un autre point aussi sur le
positionnement chirac avait choisi un
peu justement forcé par cette
candidature de balladur a changé de
positionnement ils avaient choisi la
lutte contre la fracture sociale qui
avait étonné tout le monde et la marine
le pen alors que son fonds de commerce
était pourtant la lutte contre
l'immigration
elle a choisi là aussi un positionnement
social et la défense du pouvoir d'achat
donc c'est ça fait beaucoup de points
communs je trouve avec la campagne de 95
accusations
oui je pense que il ya un autre une
autre élément de comparaison c'est la
désidéologisation
c'est à dire que jacques chirac ne se
voulait pas du tout le candidat de la
droite classique conservatrice
bourgeoise et de la même façon
marine le pen est pas pour rien qu eric
simon l'avait traité de socialiste à
assumer ce positionnement ni droite ni
gauche qui finalement est un peu le même
que celui d' emmanuel macron en 2017
elle n'a pas varié face à un zemmour qui
lui était clairement ancré à droite et
qui voulaient l'union des droites on
verra ce soir le résultat mais les
sondages laissé entendre que ce n'était
pas forcément la mauvaise stratégie et
puis elle saigne à fond sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui est la préoccupation qui
était déjà celle des français largement
en 2017 mais qui a bondi là pour cette
présidentielle en particulier avec la
crise ukrainienne et ça c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose sur lequel elle est
allé très vite en étant beaucoup plus
sûr de l'économique du social en
laissant plus à eric zemmour le terrain
de l'as de la sécurité de l'immigration
alors on va aller continuer de commenter
ça et on ira justement au quartier
général d'eric zemmour et de valérie
pécresse avant on retourne au deuxième
étage de la rédaction du figaro au coeur
de la muse drôme où on retrouve bruno
dray
merci vincent rouge continue donc mon
petit tour dans la rédaction du figaro
et je suis avec jean baptiste émergents
chef du service réseaux sociaux du
figaro bonsoir jean baptiste bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous alors comment on
va pouvoir suivre ce premier tour ce
soir sur les réseaux alors ce soir c'est
quand même un grand moment pour le
figaro et aussi pour les réseaux sociaux
parce que il ya énormément de
commentaires énormément de réactions et
c'est aussi un enjeu pour nous pour vous
de votre côté pour vous informer notre
enjeu c'est de bien vous informer sur
tous les réseaux sociaux peut parler de
facebook on a plus de 3,5 millions
d'abonnés sur twitter notre 5 aussi sur
snapshot on en a 130 milles enfin
plusieurs millions de personnes qui nous
suivent et qui veulent absolument
s'informer grâce au figaro mon travail
aujourd'hui c'est de gérer une équipe de
sept journalistes qui sont à la
rédaction qui lisent ce qui se passe sur
le journal qui essayent de restructurer
ce qui est écrit dans le journal pour
être mieux compris en compris
compréhensible sur les différents
réseaux sociaux ça peut être des vidéos
de moins d'une minute par exemple que
sont en train de faire gaspard et romain
d'ici même bien sûr
gaspard et motion designer ça veut dire
qu'ils fabriquent et conçoit des
habillages des manières de mieux
comprendre l'actualité et romain un
journaliste ensemble leur travail c'est
réussir à reconcevoir conceptualiser
l'actualité afin qu'elle soit beaucoup
mieux comprises et qu'elle respecte
aussi les usages des réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il faut dire qu'un article
c'est très différent d'une vidéo d'une
minute l'important c'est que ce soit les
mêmes angles et la même manière
d'informer alors jean baptiste émergent
qu'est ce qui va être le plus difficile
à gérer ce soir est-ce que c'est pas la
modération par hasard alors
effectivement là je reprend le micro
effectivement la modération c'est assez
compliqué parce qu'il ya énormément de
personnes qui veulent commenté qui
veulent affirmer des sensibilités et
aussi donner leur analyse ce genre de
soirée on a tous un peu un avis on a
tous une manière de s'exprimer et de
voir les choses et on veut débattre on
veut le mettre en avant le mettre en
valeur par rapport à d'autres intérêts
d'autres personnes interviewées des gens
qui sont sur les plateaux on a vu qu'il
y allait avoir beaucoup de plateau ce
soit mais aussi des réactions de
politiques et des réactions qui sont
sûrement très étonnante ou pas
d'ailleurs on verra ce que ça va donner
ce soir et c'est vrai que c'est très
important pour nous la modération cette
manière de mettre en avant la richesse
de la plupart des internautes mais aussi
éviter que y ait des débordements en
deux mots jean baptiste est ce que vous
pouvez rappeler à tous les internautes
qui souhaitent commenter réagir dans
notre chatte quelle est la charte du
figaro alors naturellement donc cette
charte existe cette charte est très
importante on la rappelle assez souvent
nos impôts nos internautes et toutes ces
personnes qui veulent absolument
commenter de manière problème comment
dire construc construite avec souvent
des articles du figaro ou alors des
artistes extérieurs donc c'est un
travail de modération ou c'est important
d'empêcher des insultes bien sûr réussir
à créer le débat créé une effervescence
entre les différents avis et de cette
manière à la rendre des lives rendre des
émissions encore plus riches riches des
internautes est riche de ses
sensibilités extérieur
merci beaucoup jean mathis énergie eau
on vous retrouve tout à l'heure à minuit
vous nous expliquerez vous nous direz un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé sur les
réseaux sociaux entre maintenant et
minuit donc à tout à l'heure jean
baptiste et quant à moi eh bien je vais
descendre prendre l'ascenseur et vous
rejoindre vincent roux dans le studio
haussmann pour la révélation des
résultats en direct a tout de suite avec
plaisir et on vous attend de pied ferme
cher brune merci beaucoup jean baptiste
et qu'on retrouvera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure en fin de soirée pour faire le
bilan de ce qui s'est dit sur les
réseaux et de commandes de ce qui est le
plus intéressé de ce qui vous a le plus
intéressé ce soit et de comment les
dernières les révélations les résultats
ont été
commentés dans dans le différentes
sphères et par les différentes
communautés du web on rappelle également
que bien entendu vous pouvez continuer à
commenter à chatter à réagir à poser vos
questions encore une fois dans le
respect des chartes de modération on va
aller au palais de la mutualité
retrouvez timothée d'hellemmes le palais
le multi de la mutualité accueille ce
soir un nouveau parti reconquête avec
leur candidat eric zemmour
oui vincent ici en direct de la maison
de la mutualité dans le 5e
arrondissement de paris la salle qui est
en train de se remplir vous le voyez
derrière moi les militants qui ont pu
entrer à partir de à 18h30 la maison de
la mutualité c'est ici que nicolas
sarkozy avait prononcé son discours
d'adieu en 2012 après sa défaite au
second tour en 2017 c'est ici que benoît
hamon le candidat du parti socialiste
avait organisé sa soirée électorale
alors ici je vous le disais la salle qui
continue de se remplir entre 1000 et
1500 1 sympathisants et militants sont
attendus ce soir est pour l'instant
peut-être que vous le voyez d'air moi
derrière moi la salle qui est assez
clairsemé il n'y a pas mille 500 1000
1500 militants pour l'instant tout le
monde en tout cas n'est pas n'est pas
arrivé du côté des journalistes près de
300 journalistes sont sont accrues sont
accrédités pardon eric zemmour lui ne
devrait pas faire d'apparitions avant
son discours son discours qui
interviendra après les résultats et un
discours qui sera prononcé entre 20h et
21h c'est une fourchette assez large qui
nous a été donné par olivier ubéda le
directeur événementiel d'eric zemmour
pour l'instant peut-être que vous le
voyez derrière moi des images de la
campagne d'eric zemmour sont diffusés
sur les écran géant on a vu des images
et bien de son discours en corse des
images est évidemment dû du trocadéro et
puis voilà ce que je peux vous dire
aussi sur sur eric zemmour c'est qu'il a
passé une journée plutôt calme il a voté
aux alentours de 11h30 un petit peu
avant 11h30 dans un dans un bureau de
vote du viiie arrondissement et on nous
dit ici que il a ensuite passé une
journée assez calme une journée en
famille l'occasion pour lui et bien de
peaufiner son discours voilà le candidat
qui est donc attendu après 20 heures
seulement ici la salle continue de se
remplir et une dernière chose vincent
sait qu'un cocktail et est organisé il
sera servi quels que soient les
résultats à l'issue du discours d'eric
zemmour un cocktail donc auquel sont
conviés l'ensemble des sympathisants
présents ce soir à la maison de la
mutualité
merci beaucoup timothée pour ses
premières précisions pour cette ambiance
ya beaucoup de questions assure eric
zemmour à mk nous dise eric zemmour
peut-il réellement espérer un sursaut de
mobilisation notamment avec les jeunes
moi je voudrais vous faire réagir un
autre commentaire celui de marcelo on
dit que la radicalité des et moore a
aidé le pen mais n'at-il pas aussi aider
macron dans les sondages en prenant des
voix à le pen on a le droit de parler ça
va pour l'instant on ne connaît pas les
résultats des résultats et on n'a pas
des estimations est ce que en tout cas
ça peut l'appel à candidature dans l'est
dans les intentions de vote en tout cas
la candidature d'eric zemmour a pu
profiter indirectement et finalement je
ne pense pas je pense que vraiment eric
zemmour ça a été à la fois lépine de
marine le pen et petit à petit les
guillon ou en tout cas le
finalement ce qui a permis d'adoucir son
image est aussi de pouvoir
potentiellement espérer si elle est
sélectionnée si elle réussit à passer ce
premier tour va avoir pour la première
fois des réserves de voix le ski pour
les sur les précédentes élections
étaient été il y avait des réserves de
voix mais qui était beaucoup plus faible
le cas actuellement donc pour moi c'est
vraiment eric zemmour
un candidat de droite à la droite de
marine le pen qui
est un vrai sujet est un sujet peut-être
plutôt comment dire qu'il sera plutôt un
handicap pour emmanuel macron s'il était
réélu président de la république on n'en
sait rien à cette heure parce que ça
permettra à la droite de se réorganiser
parce qu'ils auront une tête
supplémentaire on verra le score qui
fait mais en tout cas une tête
supplémentaire pour pouvoir organiser la
droite l air et le rassemblement
national et il a la vocation et l'envi
de pouvoir participer à un rassemblement
la droite nouveau en tout cas beaucoup
ont dit que cette campagne était
inintéressante qui avait pas d'enjeu etc
il ya eu quand même une nouveauté avec
la candidature de ceux de cette
personnalité il oui c'est qu'un il ay là
il a été un des acteurs clés de cette de
cette élection ça c'est sûr il a fait
une entrée tonitruante
il a gagné je crois de 10 points en
quelques semaines c'est cet évident moi
je reste persuadé qu'il y avait deux
projets très précis dans cette campagne
que deux personnes qui avaient une
vision on va dire de la france alors que
les autres étaient dans un catalogue de
mesures tout à fait digeste c'était eric
zemmour d'un côté mon côté c'était mieux
avant et puis finalement le président
sortant emmanuel macron même si c'était
pas très clair mais bon c'était sa
philosophie c'était mieux ça sera mieux
de 20 voilà mais les autres j'ai trouvé
que c'était
assez faible et il a pu se distinguer
grâce à ça il a eu deux épisodes qui
l'ont considérablement handicapé qui ont
finalement marqué un coup de frein à sa
campagne c'est d'abord l'histoire des
handicapés ça ça l'à beaucoup marqué je
sais que ça l'à beaucoup marqué
personnellement ça l'à beaucoup affecté
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose c'est pas tant son
soutien à poutine parce qu'on a vu qu'il
y en avait d'autres qui avaient plutôt
si la droite y avait un souhait mais
c'est surtout son discours sur les
réfugiés ukrainien alors on peut le voir
de deux façons soit c'était cohérent
avec son discours global sur les
immigrés soient s'était complètement
incohérent avec son discours sur
la chrétienté l'europe vous vous
souvenez c'était aussi le geste qu'il a
le geste à la militante marseillaise
sortant de la voiture est en fait c'est
à partir de là
on a eu
des rebonds après parce que ça avant le
discours de m quand même c'est quand
même vraiment les handicapés et surtout
les surtout les les infléchir les
réfugiés le chrétien qui lui ont qu'ils
l'ont qu'ils l'ont marqué ce qui est
intéressant chéri et moi
je reviens sur ce que vous avez dit à
l'instant je crois que ça va être une
guerre terrible à droite terrible si
marine le pen n'est pas élu si quelqu'un
de droite n'est pas élu président de la
république ne sait pas on va le savoir
bientôt mais si aucun des trois courants
des deux courants nationalistes et le
courant je dirais la de la droite gaullo
chiraquienne n'est pas élu ça va être
une guerre terrible entre eux pour
savoir qui va prendre le leadership de
ça ce qui va être intéressant au delà du
score que fera et eric zemmour qui a
effectivement tenté le début de campagne
par ses thèmes en tout cas en tout cas
médiatiquement très fortement c'est ses
devoirs on avait beaucoup dit que le
maquereau a été élu qu'il avait dynamité
le système politique français qui
étaient déjà en voie de décomposition
il faudra voir à quel point il à la
décomposition se continue que sera-t-il
qu'en sera-t-il des scores des
républicains du parti socialiste qui
était déjà mal en point ça sera vraiment
intéressant à voir est ce qu'on va se
retrouver avec finalement une espèce de
bloc central
qui pourrait être incarnée par macron
fasse un bloc extrêmes donc c'est ça qui
sera intéressant à observer dans les
dents les résultats parce que l'un des
enjeux quand même guillaume
également de cette élection c'est de
savoir qui est leader qui aura le
leadership à droite et dans ce trio
entre marine le pen valérie pécresse est
ex-aequo bien sûr et c'est difficile de
répondre à cette question puisque marine
le pen elle même ne se met plus de ce
côté là de l'échiquier puisque comme
emmanuel macron en 2010 est elle elle
considère que cette opposition n'est
plus pertinente et qu' il faut
maintenant une approche sociologique
avec d'un côté les gagnants de la
mondialisation et de l'autre côté ce
qu'elle appelle les nationaux et qui ne
ne serait naturellement dans
l'opposition qu'elle est une sensibilité
de gauche ou de droite effectivement le
la bagarre entre guillemets elle va être
entre les républicains et eric zemmour
qui est à la fois comme toujours en
politique le l'acteur est le révélateur
d'une évolution des électeurs de droite
la droite française a toujours marcher
sur deux jambes avec une plutôt
centriste est une bien la droite les
centristes un certain nombre sont partis
chez emmanuel macron on verra ce soir si
ça se confirme dans cette élection
présidentielle et les autres peut-être
qu'ils veulent une droite plus plus plus
plus plus dur plus raides et c'est eric
zemmour qui a tenté de capter cette
cette demande avec une valérie pécresse
qui se trouve entre les deux ce qui
n'est pas une position simple point de
vue votre
internaute avait raison puisque c'est
vrai que en tout cas pendant cette
campagne c'est de ça que de cela que
valérie pécresse a pâti c'est à dire
l'idée petit à petit qu'un vote utile
centriste vrai plus dans votre mac rond
quand votre pécresse en tout cas on va
essayer de savoir quel est le pouls
quelle est l'ambiance
autour de valérie pécresse on va aller à
la maison de la chimie dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris
retrouvez mathis fleuret qui s'y
trouvent depuis la fin de l'après midi
bonsoir matisse il y a apparemment pas
mal de ténors en tout cas des
républicains qui sont présents depuis
depuis plusieurs minutes
oui bonsoir ressort alors je suis bien à
la maison de lâcher lieu de la soirée
électorale de valérie pécresse alors il
ya eu une réunion en fin d'après midi
ici avec les cadors dès l'air hormis
philippe juvin qui est lui en ukraine et
xavier bertrand qui est dans les hauts
de france alors ici quelle est
l'ambiance est bien ça commence à se
remplir il ya quelques militants ça
commence à arriver la salle et surtout
rempli des 350 journalistes accrédités
j'ai plus comment parler à quelques
militants certains croient à la surprise
c'est ce qu'a affirmé dans la presse
valérie pécresse ces dernières semaines
en affirmant qu'elle même avait été je
cite la surprise toute sa vie mais
les il ya aussi quelques quelques
militants qui sont plus résigné j'ai
notamment noté cette phrase c'est pas
parce qu'on n'est pas majoritaire qu'on
n'a pas raison en tout cas tout le monde
ici attend les résultats à 20h puis la
prise de parole de la candidate et l'air
valérie pécresse juste derrière
mais merci beaucoup mathis pour ses
premiers éléments
reviendra vous voir un petit peu plus
tard dans le courant de la soirée j'ai
le plaisir de voir un mec très prudent
plaisir partagé dans un petit peu plus
d'un quart d'heure on devrait avoir les
premières estimations qui seront données
par l'ifop on est là pour tout vous dire
on est les a pas encore et ne sont pas
encore parvenus il ya un certain nombre
de sondages qui tourne on donnera les
tendances qui sont donnés par ces
instituts de sondage qui sont peu ou
prou les mêmes on rappelle les chiffres
de l'abstention donc une estimation à
24% selon l'ifop 27% selon oddo que ça
et comment je dise assassinat mais safin
et safina convient alors de dire
précisément
vous l'avez dès que vous l'avez c'est
une vous ne renoue le donner en tout cas
moi j'ai installé mon ordinateur donc je
peux vous lire je vous regarde vous êtes
nombreux sur les tchats du figaro.fr et
sur le chat youtube jeu salies je salue
pardon anthony gabbro est évidemment
charles martel alex almasy vole pas eu
leur où tu es sous des internautes très
fidèle de figaro live je vous remercie
d'être là il ya d'ailleurs pas mal de
commentaires dans le chat qui
rebondissait sur le fait que la campagne
était un petit peu médiocre voire
inexistante et qui est imputée ça au
fait que macron se représenter est ce
que est ce que c'est pourquoi une
campagne présidentielle avec un
président sortant c'est moins
intéressant qu'avec des nouveaux
candidats handfield a déjà parce que
obligatoirement un président sortant est
usée et donc donc on n'a pas la lande de
la première candidature donc en plus
c'est vrai que cela dit tout à l'heure
il a eu un
mandat particulièrement usant si je puis
dire parce qu'avec des épreuves quand
même particulièrement difficile à
traverser on dire de les geler jaune le
coc vide maintenant comme président de
l'union européenne et président
le conflit en ukraine donc donc ce n'est
pas rien mais en plus ce qui ce qu'on a
dit aussi tout à l'heure c'est que c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'il n'a pas
souhaité s'impliquer dans cette campagne
alors soit part
parce que trop de certitudes en ses
capacités soit parce qu'il n'a pas senti
il en a pas voulu parce qu'il n'a pas
senti le besoin soit parce qu'ils
étaient accaparés par la scène
internationale donc ça ça a beaucoup
joué donc c'est vrai qu'on l'a on l'a
très peu vu on a très peu entendu sur
sur des thèmes sur lesquels on
l'attendait et au moins qu'il réponde à
ses adversaires même si ce n'était pas
directement dans un dans un débat au
moins de répondre ce qui n'a pas fait
quoi donc ça c'est vrai que c'était
surprenant rarement un président sortant
a aussi fait aussi peu fait campagne
c'est une c'est une d'effectivement des
choses qui revient beaucoup dans les
dents le chat du figaro
les premières estimations commencent à
tomber dans un quart d'heure donc on va
on sera en mesure de vous donner le nom
des finalistes pour cette élection
présidentielle je reviens sur les
chiffres de l'abstention surtout qu'ils
ont
les estimations tous les cas dont on
dispose pour retourner sur le sens
profond de cette de cette abstention il
y avait un débat entre vous iv lignum
tout à l'heure sur est-ce que c'est
accidentel ce que c'est lié à à une
conjoncture un peu particulière ou bien
est ce que c'est quelque chose de plus
profond il ce qui était intéressant dans
votre éditorial jeu vendredi dernier
vous disiez c'est quand même la faute
des politiques des promesses non tenues
d impression que les jeux sont faits
alors est-ce que c'est aussi la faute
des sondages parfois non jardin secret
si manon la politique d'abord sais c'est
pas les sondages qui font la politique
ce sont les acteurs de cette politique
fin de set de cette scène politique et
si les acteurs sont pas très bon et ben
les résultats effectivement sont pas
très bon et il ya peu de monde dans la
salle c'est exactement comme un
spectacle donc je crois que
effectivement alors je ne veux pas être
trop affirmatif quand je dis c'est c'est
d'après moi plutôt conjoncturelle je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de conjoncture
bay a aussi c'est structurel dans la
mesure où les modes de communication
politiques ont changé aussi savoir que
l'on dit que la commande l'abstention
est importante chez les jeunes mais les
jeunes ne s'informent pas de la même
façon que les plus anciens et peut-être
que les nouveaux modes de communication
des partis et des candidats sont pas les
bons ou sont pas suffisamment aiguisé
pour toucher le public ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que moi je crois alors là ça je crois
vraiment c'est ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure guillaume c'est qu'il ya une
individualisation de la société le
problème c'est que on voit d'ailleurs
les clés les
des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle il parle aux français il
parle pas de la france libre avant on
avait les candidats avaient un projet le
général de gaulle évidemment il y avait
une certaine idée de la france
mitterrand aussi
giscard chirac même dont on disait que
c'était un caméléon mais il avait ce
avait exprimé un projet collectif
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué d'avoir des candidats parce
que je pense qu'ils ont un niveau qui
n'est peut-être pas le bon bon certains
d'entre eux pour pouvoir embrasser
justement tous les problèmes et donner à
voir un projet collectif et on est dans
une dans une ère c'est vrai de
l'individualisme et ça ça ne facilite
pas du tout c'est vrai la participation
10 mai de l'ain peu la défiance est pas
les affaires des plans de
l'intermittence parce que ce qui avait
été frappée en 2017 c'était moins
finalement le l'abstention puisque tout
rouge voilà un peu ou prou 80% des gens
votent la présidentielle mais quand on
regarde parce que c'est quand même un
lot normalement il ya deux tours à la
présidentielle et puis deux tours aux
législatives mais les législatives en
revanche la participation s'était
écroulé et quand on regarde et le nombre
d'électeurs qui avaient voté aux quatre
tours bien ce avait baissé de 10 points
par rapport aux précédentes élections
c'était assez stable et puis les
dernières élections intermédiaires ont
été catastrophique en terme de
participation parce que les gens
considèrent beaucoup que il faut un
enjeu qu'il voit clairement et où ils se
disent que ça pourra avoir un impact sur
leur vie pour voter sinon il voit plus
trop
pourtant il ya des enjeux là le
calendrier électoral qui est aussi
complètement saut et comme vous dites qu
effectivement les législatives tu
reviens juste après on va voter parce
qu'on a l'impression que les jeux sont
faits et est ce que le quinquennat parce
qu'on en a pas parlé de ça est ce que le
quinquennat n'a pas zappé aussi la
fonction présidentielle et n'a pas zappé
l'intérêt que les français portent à ce
scrutin guillaume dans votre édito du
figaro magazine vous aller plus loin
vous dites qu en réalité l'un des
problèmes c'est les plus profonds et
plus inquiétant c'est que la discussion
est devenu aujourd'hui en france dans le
débat démocratique
elle est devenue impossible oui moi je
suis très surpris de voir à quel point
par exemple un emmanuel macron et un
eric zemmour sont aux antipodes sur le
constat qu'il porte sur la société
française emmanuel macron continuer à
être dans une logique volontariste
expliqué il ya des éléments pour ça que
la france ne va pas si mal qu'on peut
être optimiste
eric zemmour dit c'est que c'est que
c'est quasiment la fin de la france donc
faire débattre ces gens là ensemble
c'est difficile même faire débattre une
valérie pécresse et un eric zemmour
c'est difficile on se souvient à quel
point il avait du mal à trouver des
référentiels communs et ça en corse a
fait écho à cette individualisation de
la société française où chacun chacun
est dans son monde et il n'y a plus de
deux il n'y a plus de vision partagée
c'est peut-être aussi dû à l'évolution
de notre pays nous ne sommes plus une
grande puissance c'est peut-être triste
mais c'est comme ça deuxièmement nous
sommes dans l'europe et donc les
français ont peut-être l'intuition que
le président de la république à moins d'
influence sur leur vie et leurs
capacités comme disait mitterrand en 81
à changer la vie
je suis assez d'accord effectivement
vient de dire guillaume saint-etienne il
ya une défiance qui est une défiance
aussi qui provient du fait qu'on
constate le manque d'efficacité et de et
de réel pouvoir c'est vrai qu'entre
l'europe d'un côté les régions de
l'autre ça fait des années que le
pouvoir du président de la république
finalement rétrécit et puis j'ajouterai
que les réseaux sociaux probablement
n'arrange pas cette impression parce que
les réseaux sociaux c'est alors ce n'est
pas que ça mais c'est aussi d'une
certaine façon le règne de parfois de
pas des injures enfin et de
l'immédiateté et la politique c'est
céline de la parole mais on ne peut pas
être dans l'immédiateté donc le décalage
s'accentue à mon avis il est 19 heures
52 dans huit minutes on connaîtra le nom
des deux finalistes en tous les cas
selon les estimations
on nous disposons des deux finalistes
pour ce pour le deuxième tour de
l'élection
présidentielle on va pas un commentaire
que je veux à bavois les souches de
marcelo sur le tchad et figaro.fr qui me
dit aux législatives les électeurs ont
laissé sa chance à emmanuel macron mais
ils ne le feront pas deux fois donc nous
verrons bien sûr les résultats dans huit
minutes si cet internaute à rennes c'est
difficile de se projeter sur les
législatives avant d'avoir le résultat
des pressions c'est difficile de se
projeter sur le deuxième taux avant
d'avoir premier aussi c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs est ce qu on dit généralement
que les sondages du deuxième tour sont
quand même fait avant le avant le
premier tour sont assez assez hasardeuse
voilà il donne des tendances sur le fait
que des électeurs pourraient se reporter
déjà se disent tiens si mon vote ne
fonctionne pas je peux me reporter sur
tel ou tel candidat ça donne des
tendances mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
souvent attendre enfin il faut toujours
même attendre les résultats du premier
tour parce que c'est là que les français
réalisent vraiment quelles sont les
protagonistes et comment ils peuvent se
positionner donc il faut en effet
attendre un petit peu le soir deux des
soirs de présidentielle c'est rare de ne
pas avoir de surprise quand même
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça arrive
souvent
après c'est pas la règle enfin
heureusement d'ailleurs d'une certaine
façon heureusement que tout n'est pas
prévisible et est annoncé donc oui
souvent il ya une il ya une surprise
mais en général il ya un événement en
amont qui permet de d'expliquer cette
surprise là je vois pas quel événement
aurait pu motiver un ace que ces
surprises foncière euris est ce que
justement ces surprises
c'est pas quand on analyse a posteriori
convoi l'événement qui a eu avant du
côté local surprise peut-être oui comme
dans les places financières
comme une prolongation je dis souvent
c'est une prolongation courbe la
surprise à la présidentielle c'est à
dire une tendance qui a été observé dans
les derniers sondages et qui se
vérifierait un moment au moment des
résultats l'abstention c'est ce qu'il
faut ce le plus les prévisions la
participation est l'abstention fausse
les prévisions si l'abstention est mal
estimé mais si les l'élection et reste
une élection à forte participation et ce
sera c'est normalement le cas et c'est
que tu as encore ce soir ce soir même si
elle est plus faible que prévu et il n'y
a pas de raison ici par ailleurs les
sondeurs estime bien à peu près la
participation les résultats des sondages
d'intentions de vote sont généralement à
peu près confirmer les dernières
intentions de vote en tout cas alors
dans le chatt pardon pardonnez-moi and
il ya beaucoup de débats autour de
l'abstention et des manifestations qui
qui pourrait avoir lieu en cas en cas
d'un d'inde un résultat qui ne la
recette se fait pas et effectivement il
se pose la question de savoir si les
personnes qui s'abstiennent sont des
manifestants en devenir et c est ce qu
on sait quel est le profil des
abstentionnistes en tout cas est ce qu
ils le font parce qu'ils ne sont pas
intéressés par la politique ou c'est un
moyen pour eux d'exprimer leur désaccord
en fait avec l'offre alors précisément
quand on s'abstient du coup on ne peut
pas savoir ce que pensent les gens c'est
vrai que c'est un peu la ddt le problème
de l'abstention maintenant on sait que
élection après élection le profil de
l'abstentionnisme c'est un profil plutôt
jeune pas les plus jeunes mais les gens
qui ont entre 25 et 34 ans c'est ce
qu'ils s'abstiennent le plus en tout cas
qu'ils vont voter par exemple pour un
tour de la présidentielle parce qu'ils
vont se dire à ce moment là ça peut
jouer mais pour les tours suivants c'est
ce qu'on dise précédemment bon bah sur
le second c'est déjà joué ou sur les
législatives ça ne sert à rien donc les
jeunes ont la plupart du temps ce
comportement là et ce qu'ils jouent
beaucoup c'est la catégorie sociale
c'est à dire que depuis les années 80 et
le fait qu'ils aient eu un taux de
chômage important qui a mis du temps à
abc et puis le fait que des crises
économiques soient survenus les
électeurs au mieux particulièrement les
électeurs qu'on appelle csp - les
ouvriers les employés ont le sentiment
que les hommes politiques ne leur
offraient verse aucun d'entre eux ne
leur offrait une solution qui permettait
de changer leur situation et c'est ça
qui explique pour beaucoup l'abstention
de des électeurs français
19h56 et 55 secondes on ne sera en
mesure de vous annoncer qu'ils sont les
finalistes pour cette élection
une dernière peut être une dernière
question est ce que c'est un rapidement
mais c'est une question importante
on n'a pas tellement commenter la
candidature de valérie pécresse
qu'est ce qu'elle peut espérer ce soir
elle peut espérer
d'abord une présence au second tour
puisque c'était son objectif et les
sondages de ces dernières semaines c'est
vrai ne lui laissait que peu d'espoir on
saura dans quelques minutes si la
tendance est confirmée ce qu'elle peut
espérer c'est sauver sa famille
politique
on le disait tout à l'heure le il ya une
forme de piège macro nist piège dans le
bon sens du terme en tout cas de
dispositifs mercredi ce qui fait que les
modérés et et deux camps à gauche et à
droite ont tendance à rallier celui qui
incarne c'est à dire le président
sortant cette politique là comment faire
pour desserrer cette étreinte la
question se posait avant l'élection je
pense que se posera pour le parti de
façon encore plus forte après surtout
s'il ya la tentation chez certains élus
des républicains de de partir chez dans
le camp d'emmanuel mâcon en tous les cas
à la fin de la campagne il ya une une
remontée peut-être pas dans les sondages
dans tous les cas de la candidate qui a
corrigé le mauvais la mauvaise
impression qu on a vu après le après son
meeting la vie note oui ça c'est pas
tellement traduit dans l'est dans les
chiffres en fait ça a été une impression
une impression juste d'ailleurs elle
était plus détendue comme si finalement
elle avait plus rien à perdre et mais il
faut distinguer à mon avis l'avenir de
valérie pécresse de l'avenir du parti
pour rare je vais être très franc
l'avenir de valérie pecresse à mon avis
ça va être compliqué mais se stationnent
à un tournant nationale sauf s'il au
second tour après il ya l'avenir du
parti la save est aussi très compliqué
parce que le parti vous savez il ya
comme disait le général de gaulle après
moi il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de monde
ce qui sera intéressant enfin et même si
le contexte évidemment a beaucoup évolué
n'est pas le même c'est il faudra
comparer au score qu'avait fait françois
fillon qui avait quand même malgré une
campagne difficile et aide à faire feu
vert pour cent une minute on est à moins
d'une minute maintenant des premières
estimations du premier tour qu'on va
vous donner avec l'ifop les estimations
de l'ifop il ya plusieurs internautes
dans le chat qui nous donnent leurs
pronostics donc on à maquereau le pen
trois internautes proposent au stick
macron le pen macron zemmour et macro
mélenchon et bien on va bien tout le
savoir des 6 30 secondes et peut être
également ou bien macron pécresse il
reste donc moins de 30 secondes avant de
vous annoncer les résultats de ce
premier tour la fin de cette campagne
hors norme la fin de cette campagne
si contestée par les commentateurs par
les analystes le sera t elle par les
électeurs en tout cas une estimation de
sondages de l'estimation d'abstention de
24% il nous reste plus que moins de 10
secondes et nous sommes en mesure de
vous donner le nom des deux finalistes
voilà donc premiers finalistes de ce
premier tour emmanuel macron le
président sortant avec 28,6 % des voix
pour la première estimation marine le
pen améliorerait donc son score de
légèrement son score de 2017 avec 23,9
pour cent suivie par aujourd'hui car
jean luck jean luc mélenchon tout à fait
qui fait un petit peu plus de 20% 20,1
pour cent selon les premières
estimations suivi d'eric zemmour à à 7%
y/y et yannick jadot à 4,8 pour cent
devant devant valérie pécresse qui
serait crédité selon cette première
estimation de 4 7% derrière c'est
peut-être aussi une des surprises ce
soir jean lassalle avec 3,3 pour cent
jean lassalle qui est devant donc fabien
roussel du pcf à 2,5 et anne hidalgo à
2% ensuite tu suivi de nicolas dupont
aignan envoyé avec 1 8% et des deux
candidats d'extrême gauche philippe
poutou et nathalie arthaud 0 7 et 0 6%
chacun anne barrault dams et vous savez
la primeur pour l'analyse de ces
premières écoutes et mis à jour c'est
donc le duel se reproduit c'est le
retour du tango des frais si les
estimations
sont vérifiés au filet temps donc c'est
effectivement c'est intéressant on a le
match retour
ce qu'il faut c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le score par exemple du
parti socialiste quand même 15
2% trois fois moins que le score de
benoît hamon
et l air enfin les deux parties qui ont
été quand même les piliers enfin la
droite et de gauche de la 5ème son
indice core a priori ridiculement bas
céline est ce que ce sont les
estimations à ce que c'est en tout cas
les tendances dont vous disposez
également de notre côté nous nous
n'avons pas fait d'estimation chez oddo
ksa mais les autres estimations sont à
peu près sur ces niveaux là sont très
très proches finalement des différents
sondages d'intentions de vote qui
avaient été faits à la fin de cette
semaine et pour parrot doxa également la
petite surprise si l'on peut dire cela
c'est que jean luc mélenchon progresse
encore à continuer à progresser dans les
dernières intentions de vote s'il était
autour de 16% il continue à progresser
il ferait un score autour des 20% donc
quand même mieux que mieux que prévu
mais sinon c'est vraiment ce qui était
attendu avec finalement emmanuel macro
qui parvient à faire mieux que ce qui
l'avait fait au premier tour pour une
première candidature et marine le pen
qui serait exactement sur le score de
2017 mais qui parvient à faire ce score
en dépit de la candidature d'eric
zemmour eric zemmour qui serait
seulement à 7% d'intentions de vote pas
d'intentions de vote mais de vote réels
je rappelle vous voyez si l'on se base
sur les estimations le match du second
tour et sa fiche il est là c'est donc
emmanuel macron et marine le pen qui
vont s'affronter dans l'entre-deux tours
pour le poste de président de la
république le match retour comme disait
un soldat il très en apple votre votre
réaction à ces résultats
moi le troisième homme basse et jean luc
mélenchon il a peut-être la clé du
scrutin sarr est intéressant parce que
il va pas appeler à voter ni pour l'un
ni pour l'autre c'est ce que demande est
interdite est ce qu'il va être
intéressant c'est de savoir de quoi est
composé son électorat alors j'en sais
rien mais il ya évidemment une part d
électorat de gauche qui ne votera ni
macro ni
ni madame le pen vous avez probablement
une part de son électorat qui va voter
marine le pen aussi bizarre que cela
puisse paraître une petite part qui va
peut-être voter emmanuel macron et ce
qui va être intéressant c'est pas
tellement marine le pen qui va faire son
aile va pas changer de discours elle va
faire exactement je parle sous votre
contrôle mais à mon avis est là elle va
faire le va prendre elle va continuer à
dérouler son discours en plus elle a
intérêt à pouvoir d'achat et tout ce qui
va être très intéressant c'est de savoir
comment va gérer cette histoire le
président sortant parce que si mes un
coup de barre à gauche à mon avis ils se
plantent parce que il a rien à espérer
des lectorats de macron quand on vote
macron quand on vote mélenchon bas on
déteste macron ou alors on fait barrage
peut-être à pécresse à pécresse à marine
le pen décidément excusez moi ont fait
barrage mais bon et ils sont ni ni va
être intéressant où sont nés et va être
intéressant guillaumin c'est quand même
une soirée terrible pour les
républicains
c'est une soirée terrible pour le vieux
monde c'est une soirée terrible pour les
républicains effectivement avec une
valérie pécresse ce qui serait autour de
5% je rappelle qu'en 2017 françois
fillon malgré ces affaires et des 20% il
était très très proche de marine le pen
même s'il était troisième ce qui est
intéressant selon quand on regarde les
chiffres qui ne sont pas venus dans cet
après-midi les français qui vote à
l'étranger céline c'est qu'on me voyait
énormément de vote en faveur d' emmanuel
macron ya un effondrement de valérie
pécresse dans des électorats qui était à
ses voisins et surtout un effondrement
par rapport aux dernières élections donc
question hypothèse en tous les cas
est-ce que cet électorat n'a pas ne
s'est pas largement déjà des parts est
porté sur emmanuel accro à c'est sûr que
ça lui fait des réserves de voix
beaucoup plus faible compte tenu du
score de valérie pécresse lors de ce
premier tour parce que quand on regarde
les sondages qu'on avait réalisé avant
cette élection on regardait les
répartitions sur le second tour et on
voyait que les électeurs de valérie
pécresse était plutôt disposé
majoritairement aller voter emmanuel
macron maintenant si l'on parle de
quelques 4 % de voix ça fait pas très
très lourd bon mais on peut dire
finalement un peu d'eux mêmes quand même
pour marine le pen puisque 7% même si
c'est mieux ce n'est pas non plus un
score énorme alors ça va être
intéressant dans le sondage qu'on sorte
pour le figaro ce soir on pose la
question sur les consignes de vote
puisque vous parliez de jean luc
mélenchon ce que l'on voit c'est que les
français sont très partagés c'est à dire
ils sont moitié moitié à dire il faut
donner des consignes faux pas en donner
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
blanche plutôt pour l'idée qu'il faut
donner une consigne de vote est plutôt
allé dans le sens du front républicain
ce que ne fera peut-être pas sans doute
pas jean-luc mélenchon il faut voir ce
qu'ils disent c'est à dire ils sont
partagés l'enjeu plus tôt pour ça alors
la seule chose c'est que les consignes
de vote les français sont 50% à dire il
faut en donner maintenant ils sont plus
de 80% dans notre sondage à dire mais on
les suivra pas
voilà donc en sait donc sondages à
découvrir sur le site du figaro charles
nous dit guillaume et anne zemmour a
contribué à piller les l air et l
écroulement dlr zemmour vaincrons
les deux mon général
mais en plus il ya eu sûrement une
espèce de réflexe de vote utile entre
guillemets je pense que les ya eu à
l'agoa vient d'appeler à voter macron
plus aux lattois de proximité voilà avec
dargaud qui sera madame 20h01 et les
sondages ont certainement joué un rôle
en plus il ya eu
dans la période ait eu des rumeurs un
peu folle certains ont imaginé que
quelqu un qu un second tour mélenchon le
pen était possible donc je pense qu'il
ya eu un réflexe légitimiste
pour macron qui fait que ça m'a desservi
pécresse qui était déjà donnée bas dans
les sondages
nous on la met à 7 pour ça on était le
seul institut de sondage qui la mettait
le plus bas et elle fait encore moi mais
on voyait que la baisse était très très
net en un mois elle avait perdu 4 points
et ça continuait dans les sondages
suivant effectivement la courbe s'est
prolongée 28 4% pour le président
sortant
c'est un succès
oui c'est un succès c'est bon il faut
encore qu'ils transforment l'essai il
faut qu'il soit élu ici s'il est réélu
dans quinze jours ça sera effectivement
la première fois sous la vème république
qu'un président sortant est réélu sans
passant comme la cohabitation à savoir
les échos venant d'inde enfin j'allais
dire d'un gamin parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on l'appelait à 5 ans au nom d'un
d'un homme qui était inconnu du grand
public il ya cinq ans qui s'est fait
élire la première fois à 39 ans qui a
traversé comme la diane tout à l'heure
toutes les crises possibles imaginables
pendant son quinquennat finalement il a
pu gouverner pendant un an à peu près
correct enfin sans trop d'encombrés
c'est assez étonnant c'est très étonnant
alors ce qui prouve aussi oui on dit que
les français sont
finalement s'était radicalisé certes
peut-être mais finalement madame le pen
bon vous allez me rey n'a pas changé le
contenu de son discours n'a pas changé
finalement il a très peu changé elle a
changé la posture et macron
mélenchon a fait une fin de campagne à
l'opposé de ce qu'il a fait pendant le
quinquennat s'est adouci la hongrie il
arrondit les angles à la fin et la
radicalisation des morts n'a pas marché
qu'est ce qui a favorisé le score de
mélenchon c'est l'effet vote utile à
gauche on a des indications sur ça alors
il y avait très clairement dans les
derniers sondages d'intentions de vote
et d'opinion qui a été fait sur le sujet
on avait un vote utile de gauche qui se
préparait en faveur de jean-luc
mélenchon on voyait que la progression
la plus forte était bien la progression
de jean luc mélenchon dans les
intentions de là donc et petit à petit
ça venait bien de deux candidats qui
déjà était très faible à savoir anne
hidalgo à savoir yannick jadot et aussi
de deux français qui se posait la
question entre l'abstention et le vote
ou de français qui étaient sûrs d'aller
voter mais qui nous disait déjà je sais
qu'il nous disait à ce moment là la
semaine dernière encore il y avait plus
d'un quart des électeurs qui ne savait
pas encore pour qui vous allez voter et
à gauche ça a penché très favorablement
pour jean luc mélenchon on va observer
ça on a vu tout à l'heure des images de
qg des manuels macron
on va essayer d'avoir
des premières réactions
[Musique]
a tardé à retrouver notre envoyé spécial
vincent après
guillaume
un commentaire aussi le score d'eric
zemmour 7% oui 7% c'est évidemment pour
lui une grande déception surtout quand
on se souvient des du début de campagne
assez spectaculaire qu'il avait fait cet
homme sorti de nulle part avec une offre
politique relativement inédite
l'enseignement cette élection c'est que
le vieux monde est bien mort c'est à
dire que l'opposition entre la gauche et
la droite c'est terminé lr et le ps
ensemble ça fait 7 % des voix et bien
eric zemmour c'est qu'une sorte de
victimes collatérales de cela parce que
même s'il était une offre politique de
droite original par sa radicalité
il croyait quand même que cette cette
matrice était toujours structurantes et
probablement que la force de maquereau
et le pen c'est d'avoir fait un autre
choix d'autant plus paradoxal chez eric
zemmour que ça a été dit compris dans
les colonnes quand je travaillais au
figaro il ya très longtemps un des
premiers observateurs de ce nouveau
clivage entre souverainistes et par
exemple et européiste entre mondialistes
et gentiment des nations et nationaux et
oui c'est vrai il ay là il a
effectivement observé cela comme l'à
beaucoup de journalistes mais je pense
que guillaume a raison c'est
finalement c'est finalement on a assisté
à un duel on assiste à un duel très
classique très classiques tels que l'avs
et déterminé madame le pen et monsieur
macron il nous avait promis ce duel
danser dans ce schéma idéologique là il
se produit c'est que je pense qu'en fait
eric zemmour évidemment mais même
emmanuel macron aurait dans l'idéal
souhaité débattre avec eric zemmour
parce que je pense que même s'ils sont
ils sont en désaccord sur beaucoup de
points mais je pense qu'ils l'estiment
intellectuellement et qu'il est qu'il
aurait aimé débattre avec avec quelqu'un
que
dont il estime son niveau la percussion
voilà et qu'il estime de son niveau
exactement tout noir tu dans le tchat
youtube qui ne dit macron est en train
de réécrire l'histoire carrément
réécrit pas l'histoire il l'a fait
l'histoire on peut l'arrêt on va voir ce
qu'il va nous rattraper on dit toujours
que le soir du premier tour il ya une
nouvelle campagne qui commence donc
c'est vrai que rien et notamment les
chiffres peuvent en le niveau zéro ces
gels peuvent encore évoluer quand même
non quand même et ensuite c'est une
nouvelle campagne qui commence dans quel
sens justement dans quel sens ils
peuvent évoluer c'est à dire qu'on peut
observer un resserrement entre la marine
le pen et
emmanuel macron sa basculement total je
ne pense pas parce que à ce stade estimé
vous confirmez que dans tous les cas
l'un le second tour sera bien emmanuel
macron versus marines et les scores qui
peuvent évoluer encore pendant la soirée
et ça peut compter quand même pour c'est
un second tour parce que c'était sur la
foi de sondages de premier tour qui
ressemble beaucoup à ce que l'on observe
ce soir que l'on m'avait des second tour
qui était quand même très serré donc qui
émanent pour emmanuel macron tout n'est
pas fait loin de là on va continuer à
observer ça on ira sans doute dans les
quartiers généraux
on va bientôt achevés ce premier plateau
avant d'aller justement au parc des
expositions retrouver vincent rozon
j'aimerais bien avoir une première
conclusion de votre part par rapport à
ces à ses premiers skis d'abord ça vous
a étonné les résultats ouais
je peux pas dire que je sois vraiment
étonné parce que ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure
c'est vrai que marine le pen a mené une
bonne campagne quand qu'on soit d'accord
avec ses idées ou pas donc
peut-être un peu étonné cela dit pour
être honnête par le par le score des
manuels macron donc je pense que je
pense qu'il ya eu une espèce que je
disais tout à l'heure une espèce de de
crainte de frissons que qu'effectivement
mélenchon voir marine le pen arrive au
premier tour et que vu comme ça un repli
en effet légitimiste de crainte dirais
que je pensais que ce serait plus serré
alors on va voir si ça évolue que le
score des manuels macron serait plus bas
je pense qu'il ya
un effet trompeur qui est de croire que
finalement 2022 c'est comme en 2017 et
c'est vrai que c'est pas le retour du
tango des fossoyeurs comme l'on dit
françois-xavier bourmaud et chante ça
alors si sûrement puisque les deux
finalistes sont les mêmes c'est
d'ailleurs intéressant parce que d'après
les estimations
chacun des deux augmente son score de
2-3 de trois points donc ce qui est
différent en 2022 c'est que on a un
second tour beaucoup plus ouvert on se
souvient qu'en 2017 le second tour
c'était vingt millions de voix pour
macron 10 millions pour marine le pen on
va voir ce que ça donne cette fois mais
la situation on cela a changé depuis
cinq ans effectivement au premier tour
pardon au premier tour de 2007 je
rappelle juste avant qu'on donne la
parole dès bino
24,01 pour emmanuel macron à l'époque et
21,3 pour marine le pen là ils sont
crédités respectivement de 1 autour de
28% pas un peu plus 28% point le
maquereau est un petit peu plus de 23%
pour marine le pen et au babineau qui
nous dit emmanuel macron n'a même pas eu
besoin de faire campagne il fait 28 %
est trop fort oui encore une fois faut
attendre le deuxième tour parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y en a un deuxième tour
qui est très incertain quand même hein
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que je veux bien qu'on dise
qu'il ait pas fait campagne maintenant
avec le quinquennat vous faites campagne
tout le temps des premiers jours de
votre élection vous êtes en campagne il
il a été en campagne sans arrêt
et et même le choix de ne pas faire
campagne
c'était sa campagne donc voilà d'une
certaine façon céline un mot de
conclusion un mot de conclusion bah
écoutez vous dit vous demandiez si
y'avait des surprises dans ce dans ses
résultats c'est vrai que pour nous sont
dehors on regarde beaucoup nos dernières
intentions de vote parce qu'on dit
toujours si c'est pas des prévisions en
tout cas les derniers doivent ressembler
notre dernier sondage ressemble beaucoup
pour résultat avec toutefois deux
différences celle de jean luc mélenchon
le score de jean luc mélenchon et le
score de valérie pécresse jean luc
mélenchon est déjà très haut valais
c'est de la très basse et l'institut
qu'il a il a mesuré de la manière la
plus basse et on voit que ces deux
candidats ont vu encore une fois leur
voix baisser ou monter au profit d'un
vote utile mais comme on faisait la
comparaison avec 2010 est jean-luc
polard choix de 1er niveau 1 les terres
1 % en 2017 et donc vraiment là là le
grand bouleversement de cette de cette
élection c'est quand même l'effondrement
des républicains puisque encore une fois
françois fillon était à 20% des recettes
attendues le parti soit
707 de 2 pour
encore absolument catastrophique et au
regard des français qui aujourd'hui se
disent de gauche modérée c'est vraiment
extrêmement fleith faible et anne
hidalgo n'a vraiment mais vraiment pas
parvenu à rassembler ses électeurs qui
aura que tu se reconnaissent dans une
candidature socialiste normalien déchets
vote à paris un effet anti parisianisme
dans la contre-performance du
parisianisme est en fait plus
généralement anti d'algos c'est à dire
que c'est une candidate extrêmement
impopulaire on le savait avant même
qu'elle soit la candidate officielle du
parti socialiste ça c'est vraiment
confirmer tout de suite et ce soir
malheureusement pour elle merci beaucoup
merci pour ces premiers commentaires ces
premières analyses pour ses premières
réactions on va aller tout de suite au
parc des expositions porte de versailles
retrouver vincent horeau second quelle
est l'ambiance comment a t'on accueilli
les résultats
explosion de joie quand quand les
résultats sont tombés effectivement on a
entendu les fameux slogan d' emmanuel
macron et 1 et 2 et 50 plus on a vu les
gens s'en lasser des gens crier des gens
dont on a même vu des gens pleurer vous
le voyez derrière moi la danse est un
peu retombée depuis il s'est passé aussi
une chose c'est que on suit la soirée
sur france 2 sur les sur les écrans et a
fait à chaque fois que le du vecteur de
france 2 était là l'ambiance remonter
mais sinon depuis l'ambiance est devenue
assez calme et on suit la soirée
électorale calmement on va dire
l'ambiance remonte quand on vous entend
vincent on va peut-être aller du côté de
chez marine le pen oui tout à fait on va
retrouver daphné caravaca qui est donc
dans le qg de marine le pen dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris daphné est ce
que vous m'entendez comment s'est passée
l'annoncé des résultats dans le qg de
marine le pen
oui je vous entends des écoutes et je
vous propose d'entrer dans la salle du
bois de vincennes vous le voyez sur les
images de rappel lazreg c'est
l'apaisement qui a remplacé les
incertitudes de marine le pen donc
candidate de rassemblement national est
au second tour avec 24 2% vers ce mois à
l'annoncé des résultats la salle daf les
monts et déserts mekhout daphné on vous
reproche juste après il y à valérie
pécresse qui
tentera monsieur clar monsieur en train
de s'exprimer il s'exprime en direct par
donner
au premier tour les extraits les en
estimant le débat démocratique et du
maquereau à jouer il fait prendre un
énorme c'est à la france nous courons
tous en payer le prix
vous savez j'ai construit mon engagement
politique contre les extraire de droit
comme vous je les ai toujours au match
avec force et constance car je crois
geraghty contre les extrêmes de droite
comme de gauche je les ai toujours
combattue avec force et constance car je
crois comme jacques chirac
que tout dans l'âme de la france dit non
à l'extrémisme
le projet de marine le pen conduirait le
pays à la discorde à l'impuissance et à
la faillite sa proximité historique avec
vladimir poutine la discrédite pour
défendre les intérêts de notre pays dans
l'étang tragique que nous vivons son
élection conduirait à l'effacement de la
france sur les scènes européennes et
internationales
ainsi et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne je voterai en
conscience emmanuel macron pour empêcher
l'arrivée au pouvoir de marine le pen et
le chaos qui en résulterait je les dis
[Applaudissements]
je les dis je ne suis pas propriétaire
des suffrages qui se sont portés sur mon
nom mais je demande où les hostos
électrices et aux électeurs qui m'ont
honoré de leur confiance de peser dans
les jours qui viennent avec gravité les
conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses pour notre pays et pour les
générations futures de tout choix
différent du mien qu'il envisagerait
pour le second tour
à l'issue de ces mois ci intense de
rencontre de dialogue dans les villes et
les villages qui font la beauté la
diversité et l'identité de notre pays je
veux enfin dire aux françaises et aux
français que je les aime passionnément
que mon engagement politique est intact
et que pour améliorer leur quotidien et
leur destin je mènerai d'autres combats
je continuerai à me battre de toutes mes
forces pour vous servir et défendre une
certaine idée de la france vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous venez de vivre en direct et
de suivre la déclaration de valérie
pécresse dont qui est crédité selon les
premières estimations de
4,7 pour cent des voix en dessous de la
barre fatidique
score qu'on va des 5% qui permet le
remboursement des frais de campagne
score qu'on va bien sûr commenté avec
notre nouveau plateau alors avec nos
plateaux je salue bonsoir gaël sliman
bonsoir êtes président et fondateur doxa
enchanté et fondateur avec céline bracq
qui était juste avant vous et vous
succédez à la même place arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
de la revue politique et parlementaire
bonsoir ça et professeur à la sorbonne
alors en plus lors sa directrice
générale de kantar public et judith
waintraub grand porte est il besoin de
vous présenter le grand reporter au
figaro magazine
peut-être une réaction à ce que
donc on vient d'entendre valérie
pécresse 10 k
titre personnel elle votera en
conscience pour emmanuel macron elle
assume qu'elle ne donne pas de consigne
de vote mais elle prévient que ceux qui
ne feront pas pas
comme elles prendront un risque énorme
pour le pays arnaud bennet bas ce qui
est important c'est le titre personnel
en l'occurrence c'est qu'elle ne veut
pas engager l'ensemble d'un parti qui
s'est fracturé sur la question du vote
au second tour en faveur ou non des rig
man 2 d'emmanuel macron depuis plusieurs
depuis plusieurs mois donc elle s'engage
elle envoie un signal qui est un signal
assez clair en ce qui la concerne mais
elle est finalement les instances du
parti délibéré dans les jours qui
viennent et trouver peut-être une
solution qui soit une solution de
compromis qui ne divise pas le parti
avant les législatives
aussi l'action rapide jeudi parce que
yannick jadot devrait s'exprimer oui
alors on comprend très bien les
attentions que viennent de décrypter
arnaud qui sont celles-là de valérie
pécresse ça n'empêchera pas une rude
bagarre au sein des instances les
républicains aux dernières nouvelles il
se dirigeait
pas vers une consigne de vote
claire au contraire moi ils en disaient
plus à préserver ce qui reste de l'unité
de la droite gênée de jaloux
toutes les leçons
l'écologie sera donc absente du second
tour
elle ne peut pas l'être du quinquennat
c'est pourquoi il faudra bien et vite
très vite lors des élections
législatives
regardez et enfin voir la situation en
face et agir il faudra bien voir
l'urgence vitale de la bataille pour le
climat et la biodiversité
il faudra bien voir les menaces contre
la démocratie ici et en europe il faudra
bien sortir d'une société morcelé bloqué
empêcher méprisé qui tourne le dos à la
jeunesse il faudra entendre la voix et
répondre enfin à celles et ceux qui
réclament plus d'égalité et de justice
sociale
je sais que la mission historique des
écologistes et de faire entrer la france
dans ces combats de vie et de dignité
les élections législatives en seront
l'occasion
l'écologie a besoin dès ce soir de votre
soutien financier pour pousuivre c'est
indispensable combat je vous invite à
vous rendre sur le site soutenir
l'écologie point fr pour faire un don
nous ne lâcherons rien je ne lâcherai
pas l'état du pays l'imposent ce soir
nous prenons une fois de plus nos
responsabilités sans hésitation sans
ambiguïté car l'écologie c'est la
république j'appelle les électrices et
les électeurs écologistes à faire
barrage à l'extrême droite en déposant
dans l'urne
je les appelle je les appelle à faire
barrage à l'extrême droite en déposant
dans l'urne un bulletin
emmanuel macron le 24 avril prochain que
personne personne ne minimise la menace
fondamentale que constitue l'extrême
droite pour la démocratie la paix civile
l'écologie et pour les valeurs de notre
république
mais je veux le dire au président de la
république sortant emmanuel macron
notre vote ne vaut pas caution pour sa
responsabilité dans la fracturation du
pays à force d'inaction climatique de
déni social de conformisme et de mépris
démocratique
[Applaudissements]
il vaut il vaut encore moins soutien au
projet qu'il a esquissé pendant la
campagne il revient au candidat emmanuel
macron de créer les conditions du
rassemblement d'une majorité de
françaises et de français pour faire
échec à l'extrême droite
le combat pour le climat continue pour
notre survie en tant qu'humain et pour
ce pays blessés que nous aimons tant
nous en avons le devoir
je vous remercie vive l'écologie vive la
république et vive
vous venez d'entendre que yannick jadot
qui est un petit peu en dessous de la
barre des 5% selon une estimation ifop
et qui vient d'appeler à voter emmanuel
macron pour le second tour et il a
également fait un appel à soutien
financier laure salvaing alors j'ai fait
soutien financier parce que sa campagne
a priori ne devrait pas être remboursés
puisqu'il sera en dessous des 5 selon
des estimations et puis ensuite qu'est
ce qui était intéressant chez yannick
jadot ce sont les reports de voix que
son électorat en finalement détient pour
le second tour entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen
traditionnellement et de ce qu'on a vu
dans les différents sondages la dernière
semaine les électeurs de yannick jadot
davantage voté pour emmanuel macron que
pour marine le pen donc si une réserve
de voix qui est qui est intéressante et
par ailleurs chez les électeurs de
d'emmanuel macron les sujets écologiques
la transition énergétique
l'environnement sont des sujets qui
comptent pour ses électeurs
traditionnellement au centre
kezman alors deux éléments peut-être
puisque on a entendu yannick jadot et
puis valérie pécresse juste avant c'est
toujours je rebondis sur ce que disait
alors c'est toujours très hasardeuse
d'élite cas compliqué pour les les
candidats battus de faire des appels
alors valérie pécresse elle avait
clairement dit non a si clairement l'air
elle avait dit qu'elle ne ferait aucun
appel où aucune consigne de vote puis
elle s'est reprise en disant qu à titre
personnel elle prendrait ses
responsabilités ça c'était avant le
scrutin et là elle a fait cette annonce
dans le sondage du jour du vote que nous
réalisons pour le figaro avec backbone
consulting on a interrogé aujourd'hui
les électeurs qui avaient voté pour
chacun de ces candidats et comme le dit
laure effectivement ça rejoint ce qu'ils
nous disaient dans les sondages
pré-électoraux assez massivement les
électeurs qui ont voté jadot comme ceux
qui ont voté d'ailleurs hidalgo ou
roussel nous disent d'abord laissez-moi
tranquille je prendrai mes décisions
tout seul comme un grand mais quand même
ceux qui souhaitent que qui souhaitaient
que leur candidat appelle à voter pour
l'un des deux finalistes étaient bien
plus favorable à un appel ou votre mac
ronco vote marine le pen dans notre
sondage du jour le cumul de ces trois
petits candidats qui vont les petits
scores donc on les a mis ensemble même
s'ils sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
postures bien sûr ses 43% qui
souhaitaient que leur candidat appelle à
voter macron et 7% le pen juste une
chose à léry pécresse sa posture est
aussi en ligne avec les attentes de son
électorat les sympathisants à l'air
d'abord ne souhaitait pas qu'elle donne
aux consignes globale et ensuite été à
40% sur un appel à voter macron et à 13%
sur un appel à voter le pen donc avec
cette posture là elle est plutôt en
phase avec ce court à satisfaire ses
électeurs j'ai dit on va aller justement
au qg juste après on voit surtout que la
consigne extrêmement clair de yannick
jadot est un peu moins clair mais quand
même très claire du point de vue
personnel de valérie pécresse correspond
au caractère très incertain du second
tour qui s'annonce ce soir ça veut dire
que si marine le pen l'emportent les
responsabilités seront pointés et qui
n'aura pas explicitement dit qu'ils
votent pour emmanuel macron ou appeler à
voter pour emmanuel macron prendra une
part de responsabilité d'une éventuelle
victoire de marine le pen c'est ça
qu'ils veulent éviter et notamment chez
yannick jadot parce que je pense que ce
sont mes idéaux creed et son score
s'explique en partie par le fait que
une fraction de ses électeurs se sont
dit on va voter utile et pour un verre
français voté au lycée quoi c'est voter
gauche voire à rêves voire extra gauche
donc mélenchon est ce que juste
peut-être lors google
bern ots le
vote écologiste a pas justement c'est
pas exprès clac et entre d'un côté un
vote pour macro et de l'autre côté un
vote pour pour mélenchon j'ai pas sûr
qu'il soit éclaté parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'il a été très fort en en discuter
entre nous justement les les candidats
écologistes à l'élection présidentielle
n'ont jamais fait au delà de 5.5 qui
était finalement le score de ma mère
donc ne sait pas forcément éclaté mais
en revanche
les électeurs qui étaient tentés de
voter jadot au dernier moment sont
peut-être effectivement reporter sur
macro et mêlant chant
alors à illies à marine le pen qui est
en train d'arriver de se préparer à
prononcer son discours avant de d'écouté
donc là là celle qui est arrivée seconde
au premier tour on va vite retourné voir
mathis fleuret qui est dans le qg de
valérie pécresse qui vient de s'exprimer
mathis pleurer si vous nous entendez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point sur l'ambiance est ce que il reste
encore du monde dans le qg de valérie
pécresse
plus grand monde ne l'a visiblement
alors brune brune je vous en je vous
entends très mal en tout cas valérie
pécresse a pris la parole ici il y
aquelques il ya quelques minutes elle a
déclaré que c'était une déception
personnelle et et collective elle a
aussi déclaré qu'elle votera pour
emmanuel macron ce qui a été suivie
d'applaudissements
le mot clé avant ça ici c'était la
sidération on a entendu des souffles de
déception à l'annoncé du résultat de
l'élection et du score de valérie
pécresse il ne s'attendait pas à 5% à un
tel résultat des militants
on y voit l'espoir
espoir que se lèvent les forces de
redressement du pays
ce premier tour les français ont
manifestement tenu à arbis et par le
pays un choix fondamental entre deux
visions opposées de l'avenir voilà
division la justice et le désordre
imposé par emmanuel macron au profit de
quelques-uns pas le rassemblement des
français autour de la justice sociale et
de la protection garantie par un cadre
fraternelle autour du lit des
millénaires de nations et deux peuples
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron ont bien sûr
vocation à rejoindre ce rassemblement
nouvelle fait musique de se dépasser
essentiel que je souhaite loyal et
respectueux puis durant ces quinze jours
de dérouler pour que le peuple français
le peuple souverain soit en mesure de
l'arbitré par son vote le 24 avril
prochain dans cette campagne j'ai décidé
d'être libre des attaches partisanes
pour être au service de tous et de
m'adresser directement à vous je
continuerai à le faire pour être si vous
le décidez au lendemain du second tour
sans exclusive aucune la présidente de
tous les français
qui se jouera ce 24 avril n'est pas
seulement un vote de circonstance un
choix de société et même de civilisation
votre vote n'est pas en effet sur tout
le territoire français la légitime
prépondérance de la culture et de la
langue française les us et coutumes de
nos régions et des modes de vie des
français et lois et des valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
la laïcité et l'égalité notamment entre
les hommes et les femmes
dépensent également la place que dans
notre société nous voulons donner aux
personnes face au pouvoir de l'argent je
pense par exemple à l'importance que
nous accordons à la solidarité envers
les plus vulnérables
la possibilité de jouir de droits
garantis ou encore d'accéder à la
retraite en bonne santé de votre vote du
24 avril dépendront enfin les décisions
politiques du prochain quinquennat mais
qui en réalité
engageront la france pour les 50
prochaines années la politique
migratoire sécuritaire économique
sociale énergétique européenne militaire
ou diplomatique
mon engagement sur ces sujets et sans
faille
j'assurerai l'indépendance nationale
pour faire de la france une puissance de
paix je resterai dans tous les domaines
là souveraineté de la france c'est à
dire pour les français la liberté de
décider pour eux-mêmes et de défendre
leurs intérêts je comprendrais
l'immigration et rétablirait la sécurité
pour tous par l'écouté et l'attention
je garantirai le respect de chacun
d'entre vous et tout particulièrement
des simples citoyens des fonctionnaires
et des élus trop souvent bafouée sous le
dernier quinquennat ces derniers mois je
vous ai présenté sans détour mais sans
aucune outrance les défis qui se posent
au pays et les solutions que je vous
propose dans le cadre d'un projet
travail est équilibré et chiffré c'est
avec le même sérieux que j'entends sans
attendre recoudre les multiples
fractures dont souffre une france trop
déchiré et qu'aucun pouvoir n'a su
jusqu'ici réparer la facture sociale
territoriale institutionnels culturels
médical numérique je remettrai la france
en ordre en 5 ans on lui permettre de
prendre une place éminente dans ce 21e
siècle plein de promesses et
d'opportunités car au delà de ce
redressement nécessaire mon projet porte
en effet de grandes ambitions pour le
pays une ambition démocratique avec le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne avec
une proportionnelle pour permettre à
toutes les opinions politiques de
s'exprimer et d'être enfin représentait
la fondation
une ambition économique et écologique
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
une ambition économique et écologique
qui appuient le retour de la prospérité
du plein emploi sur le localisme le
patriotisme économique et le soutien aux
tpe pme créatrices d'emplois je veux
revivifier l'esprit d'entreprise
réhabiliter la valeur travail et ré
concilier le travail et le capital par
la participation une ambition sociale
qui garantisse à tous une école du
savoir de la promotion sociale et de
l'assimilation le pouvoir d'achat des
salaires et des pensions digne un
système de santé de qualité accessible à
tous et partout un logement décent notre
pays doit s'enorgueillir de n'abandonner
aucun de ses enfants d'assurer l'égalité
la reconnaissance du mérite d'ouvrir à
chacun les voies du bonheur familial et
de l'épanouissement personnel une
ambition régaliennes enfin avec la
restauration de l'état renforcé dans ses
moyens son autorité attentif aux
conditions d'exercice matériel et moral
de ses agents un état protecteur et
juste garant des libertés de tous un
état stratège au service de la nation un
état au bon endroit toutefois mon
ambition maîtresse est d'unir les
français autour de ce grand projet
national et populaire
un projet qui fait la part belle aux
jeunes et fortifie le lien entre les
générations
un projet fédérateur pour ainsi faire à
nouveau de notre nation une communauté
de destin unis et donc invincible et de
la france un pays qui renoue avec la
prospérité et la grandeur dès à présent
j'appelle tous les français de toutes
sensibilités de droite de gauche et
d'ailleurs les français de toutes
origines à rejoindre ce grand
rassemblement national et populaire
ensemble nous allons construire avec
enthousiasme et conviction
cette victoire pour mettre en oeuvre
[Applaudissements]
on a besoin et conduire avec bonheur
notre grand pays dans le troisième
millénaire vive la république vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
voilà donc voilà marine le pen donc
arrivé deuxième une fois encore j'allais
dire comment 2017 mais avec un score qui
est en publication des premières
estimations un peu supérieur à celui
d'il ya cinq ans arnaud benedetti
peut-être un débrief de ce qu'on vient
d'entendre
elle n'a pas perdu son temps pour réagir
mais ont ils réagi tout de suite mais
dans une situation assez paradoxale
finalement parce que si bien évidemment
on refait l'histoire de cette élection
et de cette campagne il y a 6 mois au
moment où la dynamique d'eric zemmour a
démarré elle peut se satisfaire de ce
résultat puisqu'elle finalement lé
résultat qui est même au dessus en terme
de pourcentage à celui de 2010 est mais
en même temps c'est vrai que ces
dernières semaines il y avait plutôt le
sentiment qu'une dynamique s'était créée
en faveur de marine le pen et que
peut-être que elle arrivera finalement à
touche touche avec eux le candidat
sortant ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas
ce soir en l'occurrence ans les
premières est rien selon les premières
estimations m'enfin quand même tous les
instituts de sondage compte on les
regarde les uns après les autres
montrent qu'il ya entre eux trois et
quatre points de différences entre
marine le pen et et emmanuel macron là
le discours qu'elle tient c'est le
discours finalement du rassemblement
mais du rassemblement anti macro nist
c'est à dire qu'elle va essayer de
fédérer l'ensemble des antilles macro
nist pour essayer de finalement réussir
on parle du social mêmes qui parlent de
suite sur les planches en écoute
vous la bordure et
nous l'aborderons
dans la fierté du travail accompli
cette force il bosse que nous avons
construit nos marques
[Applaudissements]
dans deux fois
sous le mépris
et les insultes
mais elle est là
et pour chaque étape elle est là si vous
décidez de la préserver de l'entourer
comme vous l'avez fait jusqu'à cette
heure en dépit de tout
ce matin
il faisait beau à marseille
sur la mer fuyante
les rayons du soleil bondissait d'une
vague à l'autre ce matin
tandis que je me préparais à entrer
dans cet événement dont je ne savais
rien ne sont arrivés et bientôt
les échos de l'oyapock
frontière française
sur le brésil et puis ceux du maroni et
puis ceux de la martinique
et puis ceux de la guadeloupe
et puis le second
fidèle au premier tour
dès le premier tour
mais lisait pour leur président et j'ai
vu dans leur décision ce qu'elle
signifiait pleinement et entièrement
l'état dans lequel se trouve la patrie
et son peuple sur tous les points du
territoire un état d'exaspération et le
sentiment d'être entrées dans un état
d'urgence écologique social et
maintenant encore une fois nous le
voyons ce soir en état d'urgence
politique
car le tableau
le tableau que vous avez sous les yeux
tel qu'il a été voulue nom de notre
recette ni même du fait du peuple
français mais des institutions de la
vème république et de cette étrange
système de tirage au sort qui aboutit à
vous demander de choisir entre deux maux
dont vous sentez à la fois qu'ils sont
terribles pour vous mêmes et qu'ils ne
sont pas de même nature
et chacun d'entre vous se trouve mis au
pied du mur de sa conscience
de la décision qu'il doit prendre
c'est la condition humaine d'être sans
cesse confronté à des décisions qui sont
souvent difficiles à prendre
et bien la dernière fois que s'est il
passé
je vous ai dit ce que je vous le dirai
non
je tenais votre colère mes compatriotes
vous 12 ans j'ai parlé il ya quelques
instants je connais votre colère ne vous
abandonnez pas à ce qu'elle vienne à
vous faire commettre des erreurs qui
serait
définitivement irréparable
tant que la vie continue le combat
continue
et
c'est mon devoir de vous dire comme
étant
le plus ancien d'entre vous
que la seule tâche qu'on a à se donner
c'est celle qui accomplit le mythe de
sisyphe
la pierre aux tombes en bas du ravin
alors la remontée
vous n'êtes ni faible ni sans moyens
vous êtes en état
je me laisserais de bataille est la
suivante est la suivante autant qu'il y
en aura
regardez moi
je n'ai jamais lâché prise je n'ai
jamais cédé je n'ai jamais baisser le
regard et c'est de cette façon là que
nous avons construit cette force alors
maintenant c'est à vous de faire
dans la bataille qui arrivent nous avons
constitué le pôle populaire parce qu'ils
étaient là toutes sortes de gens ont pu
prendre appui dessus pour star en votes
et nous a menés jusqu'à ce point
les batailles arrive devant vous
ne commettons pas l'erreur de nous
fourvoyer
à peine entré sur le chemin
nous savons
pour qui nous ne voterons jamais
et pour le reste
comme je voulais dit
il y a cinq ans vous souvenez vous qu'il
ya eu quelques dégâts après notre
déclaration pour qu'ils prendraient ton
les français ils sont capables de savoir
quoi faire ils sont capables de décider
ce qui est bon pour le pays jamais une
cadron notre confiance dans la
démocratie dont vous ne devez pas donner
une voix à madame le pen
alors je le sais bien
je répète parce que des fois il arrive
que même quand je dis les choses c'est
comme si je ne les avais pas dit
alors je recommence à cet endroit du
film il ne faut pas donner le seul
joueur à madame le pen
il ne faut pas donner une seule voie
mazas blt m
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame le pen
voilà je crois que le message qu'ont
cette partie a été entendu
alors maintenant qu'allons nous faire on
va ouvrir la page et les trois cent dix
mille personnes qui m'ont parrainer
donneront leur point de vue
ceci posé
ne nous cachons pas la violence de la
déception
la violence de la déception
elle est d'abord
en pensant à tous ceux qui auraient été
entrepris et qu'il ne le sera pas
et ceci plus que le reste me cuit
ce que je me préparais à faire ce que je
croyais immédiate pas à portée de main
les belles équipes dont nous disposons
et qui était prête à se déployer pour
assumer toutes les tâches il y avait à
assumer
oui c'est une déception
mais en même temps comment se cacher je
suis comme vous entre les deux comment
se cacher aussi
la cherté du travail accompli le pôle
populaire existe t'il nous n'y étions
pas
je resterai t-il
pourrions-nous rien et nous avons
construit cette fois
je m'adresse à vous
qui êtes ici dans cette salle nous pour
vous tenir les propos lénifiants de
réconfort
aux deux bonnes line qu'il faudrait
avoir je n'ai ni bonne mine ni envie
d'être réconforté je ne connais que mon
devoir et je vous appelle à faire de
même la lutte continue
la lutte conte qui lui
le disons à tous ceux qui jusque là
n'ont pas voulu l'entendre
ici est la force
nous avons une stratégie le pôle
populaire nous avons un programme
nous avons devant nous autres élections
nous tiendrons à chaque étape notre rang
réfléchi saisit alors bien sûr
les plus jeunes vont me dire eh bien on
n'y a encore pas arrivé
c'est pas loin
fait mieux merci
voilà vous venez d'entendre vous venez
d'entendre sur figaro la de la réaction
du troisième homme de cette élection
jean luc mélenchon qui a fait selon les
premières estimations 20 8% et dans le
chat ça se ça se déchaîne un petit peu
j'ai des bords qui dit au revoir au
revoir jean luc et vole pas su 34 bonne
retraite monsieur mélenchon profitez
bien de la vie judith waintraub une
réaction
officialisé son retrait de la vie
politique
il leur a dit il faut continuer le
combat en utilisant venir une image un
peu curieuse parce que sisyphe n'a
jamais réussi à ce que le rocher reste
en haut de la montagne donc c'est un
combat est tellement éternellement
recommencer certes mais tellement perdu
première chose deuxième chose il tenait
des propos contradictoires
sur le second tour dilan gros en
substance les vous êtes intégré assez
grand pour savoir
quoi faire donc je ne vous donnerai pas
de consigne de vote c'est un peu là la
position de valérie pécresse mais leur
donne une quand même puisque pas une
voix pour voir une le pen c'est une
consigne de vote par défaut mais c'est
quand même une consigne de vote ça ne
l'est pas assez pour le mettre à l'abri
aucun où marine le pen gagnerait
l'élection pour l'instant sont les
premiers calculs et jean luc mélenchon
n'est pas revenu sur cette thématique là
à la différence de 2017 même avec russel
jean-luc mai
jean luc mélenchon ne dépasse pas marine
le pen n'ont en effet alors ceci dit il
ya quand même un motif de réjouissance
il fait plus que son score de 2010 est
déjà un tout petit peu oui mais quand
même on est a annoncé vraiment beaucoup
plus bas et finalement dans les derniers
jours on a vu à la dynamique mêlant
chance se réenclencher notamment le vote
utile à gauche se renforcer dans une
quinzaine de secondes me dit on on aura
les premières images du quartier général
d'eric zemmour qui doit donc s'exprimer
on écoute merci infiniment de votre
confiance de l'espoir et de la force que
vous me donner ce soir grâce
merci moi aussi
grâce grâce à vous je peux faire une
promesse je continuerai de défendre la
france et nos idées
et
et je suis certain que bientôt nous
l'emporterons je vous remercie aussi
pour la france car je prends chacune de
vos voix comme le cri d'un peuple qui ne
veut pas mourir
le fait
le fait que vous ayez été 2 millions à
soutenir un homme parti de rien qui
n'était pas un politicien montre que mon
message a été entendu
c'est un élément fondamental qui ne
devra pas être oubliés dans les
prochains jours et dans les prochaines
années
votre voix ne pourra plus jamais être
négligée
quelle que soit l'issue du second tour
tout le monde comprendra que nos idées
valent beaucoup plus que notre score
d'aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas su convaincre assez de nos
compatriotes l'histoire dira et dira
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas parvenus
alors qu'une majorité de français
partage nos inquiétudes et nos espoirs
peut-être en raison de l'absence de
campagnes et de débats peut-être en
raison du traitement qui nous a été
réservé de la situation internationale
et peut-être aussi simplement par ma
faute
[Applaudissements]
merci bien sûr j'ai commis des erreurs
je veux dire que je les assume tout j'en
porte l'entière responsabilité
je dois beaucoup de mes succès à mon
équipe je ne leur doit aucun de mes
échecs mais à la fin de cette campagne
mais à la fin de cette campagne j'ai la
fierté de ne pas être devenu un
politicien je n'ai jamais menti pour
gagner un point dans les sondages je
n'ai jamais travesti ma pensée et je
n'ai jamais trahi
dans les jours qui viennent vous allez
entendre tout le monde vous expliquer ce
que nous avons raté
moi je veux donc vous dire tout ce que
nous avons réussi
je veux dire à ces millions de français
grâce à vous rien ne sera plus jamais
comme avant
je vous demande de rester digne de
rester fort de garder la foi vous avez
été admirable pendant cette campagne
votre vote est un vote pionniers c'est
un vote d'avenir c'est un vote d'espoir
car les vérités que nous avons dit à la
france pendant cette campagne
s'imposeront à tous dans les années qui
viennent
je veux
[Musique]
je veux remercier du fond du coeur tous
ceux qui m'ont aidé à toute mon équipe à
tous nos militants jeudi un immense
merci
votre énergie votre ferveur
votre grandeur d'âme votre générosité
votre organisation ont impressionné la
france toute entière
je me souviens encore du mois de mai
dernier à l'époque nous n'étions qu'une
dizaine ce n'était qu'une idée nous
constations le blocage de la vie
politique française nous constations
l'état déplorable de la france et des
vieux partis à bout de souffle nous ne
savions pas quel accueil les français
nous réserverai mais nous étions
convaincus qu'il était de notre devoir
de nous lever
je me suis levé
[Applaudissements]
un an plus tard
nous voici finalement face au duel qui
était annoncé depuis 2010 est alors si
électoralement rien ne change
politiquement tout a changé tout a
changé parce que nous sommes arrivés
nous avons fait irruption dans la vie
politique et regardez nous avons dépassé
les vieux parti moribond nous avons fait
en trois mois ce qu'aucun politicien n'a
jamais réussi en 15 ans nous avons
construit le plus grand parti de france
à mes côtés une jeunesse s'est levée
cette jeunesse c'est l'interdiction de
désespérer car elle ne disparaîtra pas
les drapeaux qui ont flotté au trocadéro
ne savait seront plus jamais
alors
alors oui nous sommes déçus
mais nous avons gagné dans cette
campagne quelque chose qui n'a pas de
prix la puissance et l'expérience je
vous le dis j'ai reconquête nous sommes
puissants nous sommes forts nous avons
des militants présents dans toute la
france nous avons d intelligence
redoutable des compétences inégalées
nous nous projetons déjà vers l'avenir
je ne m'en tiendrais pas là car conquête
n'abandonnera rien tant que la france ne
sera pas reconquise
notre ligne à sa singularité et elle
n'est représenté nulle part ailleurs
nous sommes les seuls à défendre notre
civilisation et notre identité dans la
culture à l'école dans la rue dans nos
moeurs dans notre vision de l'écologie
de la politique de la société nous
sommes les seuls à vouloir réconcilier
le peuple et les élites les salariés et
les patrons les gilet jaune et la manif
pour tous les abstentionnistes et la
politique je suis déterminé à poursuivre
le combat avec tous ceux qui sont à mes
côtés tous ceux qui nous rejoindrons
dans les semaines à venir et je vous
dirai très vite la forme que prendra
notre action je veux dire pour finir
parce que je pense à la france avant
tout parce que c'était tout le sens de
ma candidature que je ne peux pas rester
les bras croisés devant les mots qui
guette notre pays j'ai bien des
désaccords avec marine le pen je les ai
abordés pendant cette campagne je n'en
referai pas la liste mais il y à face à
marine le pen un homme qui a fait entrer
deux millions d'immigrés un homme qui
n'a pas dit un mot d'identité de
sécurité d'immigration pendant sa
campagne et qui fera donc pire s'ils
étaient réels je ne me tromperai pas
d'adversaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'appelle mes électeurs à voter
pour marine le pen
il y a
il y à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grand que nous tous et c'est la france
je sais que certains de mes électeurs ne
voudront pas voté pour elle je ne les
juge pas car j'ai accepté les
différences au sein de l'union des
droites
certains auraient voulu que je négocie
ces quelques mots mais je ne suis pas un
marchand
jeu
je ne vois pas la politique comme la
négociation des intérêts mais comme
l'irruption de la volonté humaine dans
l'histoire je me suis présentée
par sens de la france je me suis
présentée parce que je crois que notre
pays est en danger je me suis présentée
parce que le duel qui était annoncé
depuis cinq ans me paraissait mener à
l'échec de nos idées je prie aujourd'hui
le ciel de m'être trompé vive la
république et surtout oui surtout les
blacks
voilà vous venez d'entendre le candidat
de reconquête eric zemmour qui selon les
dernières estimations enfants tout cas
les celle que l'on a de l'ifop qui a
fait 7 % on va tout de suite retrouvé
maxime laurie qui va nous faire un poids
sur bas sur les derniers chiffres et les
ralliements maxime loris est à vous
bonsoir à tous merci de me retrouver
pour ce point faut que je m'apprête à
vous livrer régulièrement tout au long
de cette soirée présidentielle selon les
premières estimations et ifop fiducial
communiqué depuis 20 heures ce soir le
président sortant emmanuel macron est
arrivé en tête de ce scrutin avec 28 3%
des voix la candidate du rassemblement
national marine le pen accède elle aussi
au second tour avec 23 6% des suffrages
exprimés tous deux ont amélioré leur
score par rapport au premier tour de
2017 pour sa dernière candidature à
l'élection présidentielle l'insoumis
jean luc mélenchon se classe troisième
de ce scrutin avec 20 8% des voix lors
de son discours il a répété plusieurs
fois qu'il ne fallait pas donné une
seule voix à marine le pen le candidat
de reconquête eric zemmour qu'on vient
justement d'entendre obtient lui 7 % des
voix il a appelé à voter marine le pen
au second tour viennent ensuite les
candidats placés sous les 5% des
suffrages exprimés
l'écologiste yannick jadot est pour
l'instant crédité à 4 9% il a d'ores et
déjà appelé à un soutien financier pour
couvrir ses frais de campagne la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse attendu au coude à coude avec
eric zemmour est finalement distancé par
ce dernier puisqu'elle n'a obtenu que 4
8% des voix c'est une déception
personnelle et collective
j'assume mes responsabilités toute ma
part dans cette défaite at elle déclaré
depuis son qg après l annonce des
résultats
tous deux ont appelé à voter emmanuel
macron pour le second tour vient ensuite
jean lassalle à 3,1 pour cent des voix
est en 7e position de ce scrutin le
communiste fabien roussel est lui classé
8e avec 2 5% des voix il a appelé à
voter emmanuel macron le 24 avril
prochain
de son côté nicolas dupont aignan
obtient 1,9 pour cent des voix un
résultat plus haut que celui de la
socialiste anne hidalgo à 1,8 pour cent
historiquement bas pour le ps
elle aussi a déjà appelé à voter
emmanuel macron pour le second tour
enfin les trotskistes philippe poutou et
nathalie arthaud viennent clore ce
classement de ce premier tour avec
respectivement
0,7 et 0,6 pour cent des voix poutou lui
aussi a demandé à ses soutiens de ne pas
donner une voix à marine le pen enfin un
point sur l'abstention pour ce premier
tour qui s'élève à environ 26 7% des
voix un pourcentage finalement en
dessous du plus haut niveau d'abstention
jamais enregistré pour un premier tour
mesuré en 2002 à 28 4% des voix merci
beaucoup maxime et on continuera donc de
suivre ses résultats serrés classé
réactions et les appels au vote dans les
prochains un point info vous retrouve
dans une demi heure on va aller tout de
suite dans les cartes faire un petit
point dans les quartiers généraux on va
aller palais de la mutualité avec
timothée d'hellemmes qui vient d'écouter
donc le discours d'eric zemmour quelle
est l'ambiance actuellement
sur place on a paraît-il entendu quand
même les militants restés et applaudir
longuement le candidat
alors vincent je vous ai pas très très
bien entendu parce qu'il ya une musique
qui retentit dans la maison de la
mutualité et vous l'entendez à l'instant
les militants qui sont en train de
donner de la voix alors qu'eric zemmour
descend de la tribune eric zemmour qui
vient de prononcer son discours un
discours d'une petite dizaine de minutes
comme cela nous avait été annoncé vous
l'entendez derrière il ya beaucoup
d'ambiance en ce moment dans la maison
de la mutualité c'était loin d'être le
cas jusqu'à l'arrivée d'eric zemmour les
militants qui se sont très clairement
réveillé avec l'arrivée de leur candidat
eric zemmour qui est apparu assez ému un
live viennent de là peut dire pendant de
longues minutes à l'issue de son
discours d'eric zemmour on le voyait un
trait et murs son visage était assez à
ses empreintes d'émotion presque au bord
des larmes au moment d'être applaudi par
les militants il était entouré de ses
soutiens stéphane ravier par exemple
jean frédéric poisson
voilà il pense que pour ce que vous me
semblez ce que j'ai cru comprendre dans
votre question certains certains
candidats ont été applaudis d'autres ont
été copieusement hué pour ceux qui ont
été hués jean luc mélenchon l'a été
assez copieusement à chaque fois qu'il a
que ce moment ont été prononcées ici à
la tribune notamment au moment des
résultats puis lors de son discours et
un public ici clairement acquis à à
marine le pen marine le pen qui a été
applaudi lorsque eric zemmour a annoncé
qu'il appelait à voter pour elle un
accueil et un petit peu plus contrastée
pour valérie pécresse au moment où elle
est arrivée sur scène on a vu les images
en tout cas de son arrivée sur scène eh
bien il ya eu des huées et des
applaudissements au moment donc où elle
a commencé son discours et puis ensuite
lorsqu'elle a annoncé qu'elle appelait à
voter pour emmanuel macron des ben
voyons sont sortis la tête de toute
cette de toute cette foule à des bancs
voyons assez ironique et valérie
pécresse qui a été qui a été hué à ceux
à ce moment là voilà et puis là vous le
voyez peut-être derrière moi le discours
d'eric zemmour est terminée et donc les
sympathisants qui sont en train de
quitter la salle un cocktail est
organisée au troisième étage 7 de cette
maison de la mutualité est-ce que les
sympathisants vont s'y diriger ou bien
vont-ils tout de suite et bien quitté
les lieux et rentrer chez eux réponse
dans quelques minutes
merci beaucoup timothée peut-être avant
que justement on conclut ce ce deuxième
plateau votre réaction par rapport à ce
qu'on vient d'entendre d'abord de la
part de timothée également ce discours
d'eric zemmour qui est jusqu'à présent
le seul qui a appelé à voter le pen pour
marine le pen pardon non en fait comme
souvent les candidats suivent un petit
peu leurs électeurs et non l inverse
quand on regarde dans notre sondage du
jour du vote pour pour le figaro ce que
disaient les électeurs qui votaient
zemmour qui voter mélenchon ou qui
votait et pécresse on voit qu'on
retrouve à peu près le continuum des
différentes postures chez zemmour
c'était très clair un vote massif en
faveur de marine le pen pour entre les
deux tiers et les trois quarts des
électeurs qui avaient voté zemmour au
premier tour et très rares étaient ceux
qui envisageaient de voter macron les
autres c'était une abstention donc
zemmour avait intérêt à être sur une
posture très clair dans le cas de
mélenchon c'est un petit peu différente
dans notre sondage du jour d'hui votre
comme dans les sondages qui était
réalisé auparavant par paradoxal on
était sur un rapport autour de 30 %
d'électeurs qui disait j'irai voter pour
emmanuel macron de 20% un peu plus qui
disait j'irai voter pour marine le pen
et les autres qui disait qu'il
s'abstiendrait mais jean-luc mélenchon a
voulu aller un peu plus loin en
suggérant un peu plus qu'il fallait
faire barrage à marine le pen mais sans
dire
explicitement
vous avez raison il n'a pas dit
explicitement contrairement à zemmour
pour le pen il n'a pas dit explicitement
j'appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron
jadot l'a dit parce que c'est ce qui
attendait ses électeurs dans le cadre
mélenchon je rappelle un électeur sur
deux qui a voté mélenchon nous dit au
second tour macron le pen c'est peste et
choléra je n'y vais pas mais après ils
penchent pour ceux qui vont voter il
penchait un petit peu plus en faveur de
d'emmanuel macro c'est à peu près la
posture kaka adopté jean luc mélenchon
qu il est en phase avec les attentes de
son électorat il est un peu plus clair
ou un peu moins obscur qu'il ne l'avait
été il ya cinq ans et ça lui avait été
reproché à l'époque par ses électeurs
eric zemmour est beaucoup plus claire
son appel à voter marine le pen que
finalement jean luc mélenchon les dans
sa consigne de vote clairement on voit
bien que chez jean luc mélenchon il ya
un exercice rhétorique il répète quatre
fois pas une voix pour marine le pen
mais in fine et il ne revient il revient
finalement à ce qu'il a toujours dit il
va consulter ses partisans ses militants
pour savoir quel sera le choix qui sera
fait entre l'abstention ou le vote en
faveur de d'emmanuel macron mais je
pense qu'il dise on il reste extrêmement
prudent en la matière pour eric zemmour
il n'a pas tellement le choix parce que
si vous voulez un eric zemmour à 7%
c'est pas un eric zemmour au-delà de 10%
donc qu'on le veuille ou non c'est quand
même pour lui un échec au regard de ce
qu'il imaginait de son score il ya
encore quelques semaines voire quelques
jours en bosnie car il est très en-deça
de l'ensemble des sondages alors il peut
évidemment exciper le fait il a dit
d'ailleurs dans son discours que
finalement il fait mieux que les deux
anciens partis de gouvernement ce qui
est une réalité quand même et ce qui en
dit long sur l'effondrement des partis
de gouvernement mais bon il est dans une
situation où il n'y a pas tellement le
choix parce que je partage qui a été dit
une grande partie de son électorat de
toute façon se tournera au second tour
vers marine le pen oui gmail une formule
le site quand il parle de ses amis qui
l'ont encouragé à négocier les quelques
mots ce qu'il appelle les quelques boucs
qui l'apprenant selon nos informations
c'est une discussion qui était très
active hier soir oui c'était très actifs
sauf que marine le pen avait dit qu'elle
elle n'avait rien à négocier et que tu
feras absolument ce qu'il voulait
sachant que
sont les acquis nat et les inclinaisons
de son électorat sont celles que dit
arnaud c'est-à-dire massivement anti mac
monde donc pour le pen lorsque je
reviendrai sur jean luc mélenchon et ses
électeurs je pense que c'était compliqué
aussi pour lui de prendre un engagement
très fermes pour tous ces électeurs
puisque dans dans les sondages du jour
de vote aussi ce qu'on voit c'est que
45% des électeurs de mélenchon ont voté
pour lui par adhésion à ses valeurs mais
on a aussi 30% des électeurs de
mélenchon qui ont voté pour lui un vote
utile donc il ya quand même c'est 30% là
qui sont pas forcément dans un vote
d'adhésion au total ni aux candidats ni
à ces thématiques
beaucoup d'électeurs notamment de gauche
et de centre gauche certainement qui ne
se reconnaissaient pas en tout cas dans
le premier tour dans le candidat
emmanuel macron qui ont voter mélenchon
même de son touch même de centreur ils
se disent de centre gauche voyez c'est
de toute façon c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui de se positionner sur l'axé
droite-gauche aider des électeurs qui
peuvent se dire de centre gauche qui
n'ont pas voulu voter pour macron pour
exprimer aussi quelque part une
contestation une
c'est un peu comme 2002 d'ailleurs un
mécontentement quelque part et en même
temps qu'ils sont persuadés de voter
ensuite au second tour pour mâcon on va
peut-être justement emmanuel macron ne
s'est pas encore exprimée on va
peut-être essayer de retrouver vincent
rendront au parc des expositions porte
de versailles quartier général donc
des partisans d' emmanuel macron
vincent quand est ce que le candidat le
président
le candidat président le président
candidat doit s'exprimer
oui alors le candidat macron devrait
arriver d'ici quelques instants on n'a
pas encore les détails effectivement
pour l'instant vous voyez sur l'image de
renault reste avec moi en train de
filmer le le podium sur lequel il va
s'exprimer en attendant beaucoup de
ministres sont présents bruno le maire
qui arrivait il y a une dizaine de
minutes par miss monde a vu françois
bayrou qui était à côté je darrieussecq
qui à côté moi beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de politiques qui sont là alors
que anne hidalgo dans un sex crime et
sur france 2 c'est pour ça que
j'entendais des bruits ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'en fait à chaque fois
qu'un candidat s'est exprimée dès que
soutenu emmanuel macron il ya eu des
grandes salve d'applaudissements comme
on pouvait s'en douter en tout cas nous
nous attendons toujours évaluer le
maquereau qui devrait arriver d'ici à
l'instant
merci beaucoup vincent pour ces
précisions et bien on va suivre donc et
on attend de pied ferme l'arrivée d'
emmanuel macron vous nous signaler dès
que c'est le cas et on décrochera tout
de suite un mot de conclusion peut-être
pour terminer ce plateau on va de
nouveau et j'ai dit en plaisantant la
conclusion c'est le suspense reste
entier mais en fait je le pense vraiment
vu l'état des forces ce soir tout peut
arriver au second tour pardon pour
gignac une lacune personnes qui
appellent pour l'instant à voter marine
le pen oui certes mais c'est pas grave
marine le pen s'est clairement
positionné en candidate de tous sauf
macron elle ne fera pas le tri parmi les
gens qui voudront bien se tenir et c'est
un créneau porteur oui je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que dit judith je
veux pour vous situer les choses en
milieu de semaine dernière intentions de
vote on était sur ce rapport 28-24
macron le pen on avait un second tour
dans lequel simplement 41% des électeurs
qui étaient sûrs d'aller voter au second
tour nous disait je voterai macro 34%
nous disait je veux être à le pen et 25
% disaient que c'était encore une très
grande incertitude entre votes blancs et
nuls et choix d'un des deux candidats
donc on est quand même dans
l'incertitude et cette avance de quatre
points des manuels macro et y compris
ses annonces de ralliements des uns et
des autres c'est encore largement un
trompe-l'oeil l'élection contrairement à
ce que pensaient les français dans l'ue
de nombreux sondages qu'on avait réalisé
avec le figaro les français
contrairement à ce qu'ils pensent elles
cette élection n'est pas joué d'avancé
gueye vous fait pas du suspense
d'instituts de sondages la non non non
vous êtes vous avez vraiment une
incertitude alors je partage qui vient
d'être dit c'est vrai que facialement ce
soir c'est plutôt un succès pour
emmanuel macron mais il reste une grande
incertitude pour deux raisons d'abord
les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
c'est quand même véritable angle mort
pour le second tout et en devient le 16e
sont rassemblés devant le cirque d'hiver
ce soit oui et deuxièmement c'est que
finalement aujourd'hui il faut être
clair les électeurs sont assez affranchi
des consignes de vote quelle qu'elle
soit surtout dans un contexte de
recomposition du champ politique donc en
effet il ya quand même encore une marge
d'incertitude pour ce second tour
d'élection présidentielle juste est une
toute dernière question arnaud est ce
que cette élection illustre la thèse de
votre dernier livre sur justement la d
re election du politique sic hammam on
regarde le taux d'abstention est quand
même assez fort en l'occurrence moins
fort qu'en 2010 moins fort oui il est en
faillite et quand même c'est le deuxième
le plus fort de l'histoire de la vème
république donc qu'on le veuille ou non
il ya aujourd'hui une relation qui est
pour le moins distant dû à la politique
est quand même qu'on le veuille ou non
le rite électorale c'est ce qui fonde la
relation aux politiques donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une défiance et le fait
qu'ils aient finalement un candidat qui
certes domine mais il domine sur un
champ de ruines dit quelque part d'une
certaine manière en effet que le
politique jeu aujourd'hui plutôt mal en
point
merci bonsoir benedetti gaël sliman
merci d'être venu judith waintraub on
vous retrouve dans les pages du figaro
magazine à bientôt pour un prochain live
on va tout de suite retrouvé daphné
caravaca et raphaël lazreg qui se trouve
dans le qg de marine le pen
bonjour vous m'entendez je sais pas
bonjour on est en direct bonjour
moi pendant vous appelez belge préfère
ne pas répondre en fait je préfère ne
pas prendre à la télé ouais non mais je
crois de
[Musique]
barinas c'est qu'on est heureux mais
vous y attendiez mais je préfère ne pas
être à la télé en tout cas ici
l'allégresse est au rendez vous sans
aucun doute lors des prises de parole
des différents candidats qu'on a pu voir
sur le grand écran juste ici entre
yannick jadot valérie pécresse et cetera
tous ont été hués chef eric zemmour
lorsqu'il a annoncé il a appelé à voter
pour marine le pen la suite du programme
de ce soir vous vous en doutez va
consister à célébrer cette victoire
remportée avec trois points d'avancé
devant jean luc mélenchon va désormais
se rapprocher des sympathisants qui
accepteront de nous parler pour qu'ils
puissent pour appliquer leur soirée
électorale
merci beaucoup daphné caravaca on
retrouve peut-être tout à l'heure donc
avec à un militant qui acceptera de
parler au figaro je salue tout de suite
notre invité qui vient d'arriver jérôme
sainte-marie bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
politologue et président d'un institut
pôle inbox et on va attendre notre
deuxième invité on va pour cela de
retourner tout de suite dans un des qg
sera peut-être un petit peu moins
remplie que celui de marine le pen c'est
le qg de la candidate a l'air valérie
pécresse on va retrouver mathis fleuret
oui est-ce que vous m'entendez brune
sens très bien je vois qu'il ya plus
grand monde derrière vous est ce que
vous êtes oui le seul
alors je ne suis pas le seul mais
presque quasiment tous les militants ici
son parti vous l'imaginez évidemment
beaucoup de déception c'est le mot qui
ressort de la bouche de tous les
militants que l'on a pu interroger
jusque là surtout au vu du score
4,7 pour cent pour l'instant selon les
chiffres que l'on a alors il ne
s'attendait pas à un tel échec les
militants que l'on a pu interroger m'ont
dit qu'ils allaient voter blanc julien
oberle
l air que l'on a pu interroger nous a
dit que sous les 5% on entrerait dans un
dans 1 ou dans une autre dimension
pardon puis il a dit que l'art et que
valérie pécresse était sorti de son
match pendant la campagne
merci mathis fleuret et on vous retrouve
très certainement tout à l'heure
j'accueille sur sur le plateau émile
leclerc bonsoir vous travaillez donc
vous êtes directeur d'études chez oddo
ksa il veut que merci merci d'être avec
nous et jérôme simple arrêt que je vais
présenter peut-être une réaction sur ses
résultats
que dire
que dire déjà parce que s'il ya quelque
chose copé différence c'est que quand
même ce résultat il est l'illustration
de votre thèse c'est le bloc contre bloc
oui enfin c'est surtout ça montre le
renforcement du bloc élitaire très
nettement on avait déjà vu ce phénomène
là lors des européennes lorsque la liste
bellamy avait été concurrencer fortement
à la liste l'oiseau est compris dans des
villes réputées très adroit très
traditionaliste là on voit bien que le
parti de l'ordre le parti enfin
qu'effectivement il ya une forme de
réunification
idéologique et politique de ce qu'on
peut appeler tout simplement comment
dirais-je la française et non pas dire
la bourgeoisie
une question peut-être avouent leur
avant de continuer de voir ce que révèle
le sondage que vous avez fait
il pour le figaro avec backbone
consulting dans le baromètre mensuel
pour que vous faites pour le figaro
magazine
vous insistez sur la popularité des
candidats et vous étudiez justement la
corrélation entre la popularité et les
scores
enregistrés aux élections est-ce que là
il ya une corrélation entre les entre
les deux ou bien est ce que on a observé
je pourrais dire un effet rocard vedette
dans les sondages mais pas dans les
urnes
alors vaut d'être dans les six mois je
voudrais le dire vite parce que ce qu'on
remarque surtout dans ce baromètre pour
le figaro magazine avec epoca c'est
justement que les côtes d'avenir des
principales personnalités politiques
aujourd'hui n'atteignent absolument pas
les niveaux que les personnalités
politiques des encore 10 15 ans
atteignait dans notre baromètre personne
ne dépasse les 50% de cote d'avenir dans
notre baromètre déjà on peut dire que
cette on parle beaucoup de cette
désaffection à l'égard du personnel
politique on le voit effectivement dans
les côtes d'avenir est donc cette année
finalement ça confirme cette comment
dire ce mécanisme qui avait commencé qui
avaient débuté dès 2017 avec
des votes à la fois
poupart adhésion qui baisse c'est à dire
que le vote par conviction et de moins
en moins le cas est de moins en moins
présent chez les électeurs un vote un
peu plus flottant entre différents
candidats et on l'avait vu on avait
discuté ensemble sur les hésitations
pour le premier tour l'électorat
aujourd'hui en france étaient en tout
cas extrêmement hésite entre plusieurs
candidats parfois même entre trois et
quatre candidats donc c'est vrai qu'il
n'observe plus en tout cas ces
corrélations qu'on pouvait voir il ya
quelques années encore emile un premier
commentaire une première analyse d'abord
par rapport au résultat que l'on annonce
depuis une heure c'est pas une grande
surprise âge pour la majorité des gens
qui suivent les les enquêtes puisqu'on
retrouve finalement des résultats assez
proches de ceux qui étaient présents
dans les dernières intentions de vote il
ya des tendances qui sont poursuivis
relate ans jean luc mélenchon depuis
quelques semaines on voyait qu'il qu'il
montait dans les enquêtes et il se
retrouve aujourd'hui un peu plus de 20%
donc un niveau équivalent à celui qu'il
avait fait en 2017 les deux gros
candidats qui étaient annoncées dans les
enquêtes depuis le départ sont bien les
deux qualifiés au second tour donc ya
pas forcément de grandes surprises je
rebondis sur ce que vous disiez à
l'instant dans notre enquête il ya eu
effectivement beaucoup d'indécis et des
gens qui sont décidés vraiment au
dernier moment on a 26 % des électeurs
qui nous disent j'ai choisi mon mon
candidat au cours de la dernière semaine
et même 13 % sur le dernier week-end
donc c'est vraiment dans les derniers
jours dans les dernières heures que pour
certains électeurs ça s'est joué c'est
ça que vous le monde et ça ça fait ça a
pu faire bouger les choses et on voit
que des tendances se sont poursuivis
comme pour celle celle de jean luc
mélenchon par exemple un des phénomènes
quand même de la soirée c'est
l'effondrement des partis de
gouvernement
et en particulier
d'anne hidalgo et de valérie pécresse un
commentaire pas ça qu'on vous
interpréter ce gouvernement ont été
remplacés ils ont vu effectivement leurs
cadres elle est peu à peu vers depuis
2016 vers la république en marche pour
appliquer à peu près le programme qu'ils
avaient appliqué ensemble la couverture
européenne c'est bien parce qu'il ya eu
une forme d'homogénéité des politiques
publiques que ce clivage gauche droite
et que ce cette alternance n'avait plus
de s'en soucier de français que ce
clivage a été largement remplacé on voit
bien que le clivage gauche droite n'est
plus structurants au niveau national est
une des raisons je pense de la
volatilité de l'électorat c'est
justement qui en moins de krill de
clivage qui sont particulières là à
l'autre qui cohabitent le gris le
clivage entre souverainistes à lyon
populiste et progressive d'un côté et
plus au clivage entre gauche et droite
ce qui fait qu'il ya plusieurs
combinaisons possibles et que le coût en
quelque sorte du déplacement d'un
candidat vers un autre est beaucoup plus
facile qu'à l'époque où c'était sur un
linéaire unique et donc voilà donc cette
recomposition
comment dirais-je continue il y avait
quand même cette perspective d'union des
droites qui est quand même en crise
majeure aujourd'hui si les mots ont un
sens 7 % ce n'est pas 24% et donc vous
avez effectivement cette utopie comme on
ira jusqu'au retour rêver au clivage
gauche-droite voulu par eric zemmour n'a
pas fonctionné et d'une certaine manière
celui le retour à l'union de la gauche
voulue par mélenchon il s'en sort mieux
à 20% mais se retrouvent ce soir dans
une impasse stratégique majeur son appel
tout sauf le pen exposé l'exposent un
discrédit encore croissant dans les
catégories populaires il va falloir que
les militants la france insoumise macro
est réélu et qui iront dans les
mouvements sociaux il y en a comme ni
gilet jaune rendre compte devant les
catégories populaires de cette position
est pourtant emile
à l'instant on a vu justement grâce au
sondage qui a été fait pour le figaro
que la majorité des électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon est plus favorable à faire
barrage à marine le pen alors ces gars
calme maintenant c'est une majorité
relative en fait vous avez 55 % leurs
électeurs qu'ils disent je ne souhaite
pas que jean luc mélenchon appelle à
voter pour l'un ou pour l'autre mais 28%
qu'il souhaite que que j'ai avec
mélenchon appelle à voter pour emmanuel
macron et 16% pour marine le pen donc il
plonge davantage effectivement en faveur
de d'emmanuel macron mais une majorité
ne souhaite pas qu'ils aient de consigne
de vote c'est pas forcément surprenant
souvent les électeurs préfèrent aussi
choisir par eux mêmes d'ailleurs il ya
là 80 % qui nous disent toutes manières
je sais pour qui je vais voter je n'ai
pas besoin qu'on me donne l'information
que la shoah donné pratiquement une
consigne de vote il est sorti de
l'ambigüité il en sortira ses dépens il
ya d'autres sondages dantas a peut-être
montré un car un quart et la moitié qui
s'abstenait là il a bien cela n'appelle
à voter pour mâcon a continué la lourde
du mak ronis mort
consulter ses militants en ligne comment
comment 2017 je suis toujours très
méfiants que la consultation dans toutes
les structures partisanes mais pour un
parti qui n'a pas de structure existe à
l'état gazeux comme il le dit comme la
france a soumises je suis pas trop
inquiet sur le soutien qui le qui sera
apporté à la ville a du mal je pense
qu'il a quand même une cohérence
idéologique en faisant cet appel on peut
considérer effectivement comme vous le
disait que ce sera difficile pour
certains militants dans certaines
manifestations maintenant il ya une
cohérence idéologique celle d'un champ
il a toujours fait barrage à l'extrême
droite ç'a toujours été pour lui un
leitmotiv est donc entre à choisir entre
la peste et le choléra pour lui il a
quand même fait un choix en tout cas
dans le tchat avant de vous donner la
parole ça réagit beaucoup beaucoup en
tout cas sur le chat du figaro.fr merci
date avec vous et ça réagit surtout
beaucoup à la défaite de la candidate lr
valérie pécresse ou bill 08 qui qui
abondent dans votre sens en disant que
désormais le clivage gauche droite et le
clivage nationaliste versus mondialistes
il déclare également l air mérite de
disparaître et charles martel qui est un
internaute fidèles
déclare lui aussi que l air mérite cette
déculottée alors guillaume bernard vous
envoie un message
d'ailleurs j'ai honte je regrette de ne
pas pouvoir être là ce soir ce que
débattre avec jambes sa taille aurait
été un honneur et bien on attend
guillaume pour le deuxième tour vous
attend de pied ferme on vous souhaite un
bon rétablissement et vous
voilà donc c'est bon on lui dit
directement et surtout vous aurez eu le
plaisir de débattre avec émilie leclerc
et laure salvaing lors précisément sur
les scénarios de reports de voix des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon est ce
que vous avez chez kantar les mêmes
données que celles qu'on entend ça c'est
à peu près la même chose a effectivement
on est aux alentours de 28 27 28 30 %
des électeurs de mélenchon qui
voteraient pour macron second tour et
puis plutôt aux alentours de 20
20 % qu'ils voteraient pour marine le
pen et quand il dit mélenchon je vais me
retourner vers les militants pour savoir
et s'est donné une consigne ou pas de
vote faire attention je pense que son
résultat du premier tour c'est pas juste
ses militants qu'ils y ont apportées ces
20% d'intentions de vote à temps quand
même c'est 20% du résultat de vote je
crois que je le rappelais tout à l'heure
il ya 30 % des électeurs de macron qui
disent qu'ils ont voté macron parce que
pour eux c'est un vote utile pas
forcément par conviction à ses idées et
je crois que le vote
mélenchon est aussi un vote de
mécontentement à l'égard du pouvoir en
place donc et pas uniquement de
contestation comme on peut le voir
traditionnellement
eu trois autres suffisent ils en réalité
ce sont ces vraiment 3 3 premiers bah
oui évidemment il ya eu un vote utile à
gauche il ya eu un vote utile au centre
centre-droit et puis un vote utile aussi
il ya sans doute beaucoup d'électeurs de
tête d'eric zemmour puisqu'ils
attendaient devant eux étaient accros et
encore il va du maquereau est un vote
utile
oui exactement pour beaucoup de gens qui
sont soit plutôt de droite de droite
modérée ou de gauche modéré bien se dire
au moins je suis sûr qu'il ya un
candidat alors qu'il n'est pas
totalement en accord avec mes
convictions mais qui est assez proche et
puis je considère qu'il a été plutôt un
bon président le bilan des manuels
macron dans les dents les nerfs d'argent
kate a été largement réévalué
positivement par les français donc il ya
ce sentiment là que finalement c'est
peut-être pas le président idéal mais il
est pas si mauvais que ça et donc je
préfère lui à soi quand vous êtes plutôt
de droite jean luc mélenchon soit quand
vous êtes plutôt de gauche marine le pen
le côté on va poursuivre le débat maxime
laurie vient de ou rejoindre 21h31 ont
fait un point info avec les derniers
résultats des dernières déclarations les
dernières réactions alors qu emmanuel
macron se trouve près de balard donc il
n'est plus très loin du parc des
expositions de la porte de versailles où
il est attendu pour prendre la parole
c'est le dernier candidat à ne pas avoir
fait de déclarations ce soir
8 vincent des scores qui s'affine et se
précise au fil des minutes selon les
dernières estimations ifop fiducial
publié communiqué un petit peu avant 21h
ce soir le président sortant emmanuel
macron est arrivé en tête de ce scrutin
avec 28 3% des voix on attend d'ailleurs
encore son discours qui devrait arriver
dans quelques minutes la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen
accède elle aussi au second tour avec 23
6% des suffrages exprimés tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté pour emmanuel
macron sont appelés à rejoindre notre
rassemblement at-elle clamé après
l'annnonce de sa présence dans le duel
final pour la présidence de la
république il est aussi important de
rappeler que tous deux ont amélioré leur
score par rapport au premier tour de
côté jean luc mélenchon lui se classe
troisième du scrutin avec 20 8% des voix
lors de son discours il a répété
plusieurs fois qu'il ne fallait pas
donner une voix à la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen le
candidat de reconquête eric zemmour
obtient lui 7% des voix il a appelé de
son côté à voter pour marine le pen au
second tour en promettant à ses
électeurs de continuer de défendre la
france et ses idées viennent ensuite les
candidats placés sous les 5% d'abord
l'écologiste yannick jadot pour
l'instant crédité à 4,9 pour cent des
voix la candidate des républicains
valérie pécresse attendu au coude à
coude avec eric zemmour est finalement
distancé puisqu'elle n'a obtenu que 4 8%
des voix tous deux ont appelé à voter
emmanuel macron au second tour vient
ensuite jean lassalle à 3,1 pour cent
des voix avait classé 7e de ce scrutin
le candidat du parti résistons ne s'est
pas encore exprimé lui non plus après
l'annoncé des résultats de son côté le
communiste fabien roussel qui a appelé à
voter emmanuel macron lui aussi est
classée 8e avec 2 5% des voix
nicolas dupont aignan obtient 1 9% des
voix et die j'appelle les français à
tout faire pour faire barrage à emmanuel
macron en conclusion de son discours
enfin la candidate anne hidalgo la
socialiste a obtenu un score
historiquement bas pour le ps à 1,8 pour
cent et les trotskistes pardon philippe
poutou et nathalie arthaud viennent
clore le classement de ce premier tour
avec respectivement 0,7 et 0,6 pour cent
des voix
merci beaucoup merci maxime laurie on va
tout de suite retrouvé mathis fleuret
qui est dans le qg de valérie pécresse
et qui est avec un militant les
républicains j'imagine déçu mathis
fleuret
oui bruno ceyssat je suis avec terence
qui est militant républicain tout
d'abord terence bas une première
réaction après la défaite de valérie
pécresse bah oui évidemment on est déçu
en revanche on se faisait pas forcément
d'illusions au jeu des sondages qui qui
était assez mauvais ces derniers jours
quant à notre possible qualification au
second tour en revanche on s'attendait
pas à un tel score
mais
la pilule va passer et le courant de
droite républicaine survivra j'en suis
certain
alors emmanuel macron ne représentait
absolument pas la droite républicaine on
l'a vu pendant ces cinq dernières années
il a cessé de fluctuer entre la gauche
et la droite et la droite républicaine
avait certainement pas non plus chez
marine le pen ni chez eric zemmour donc
on continuera à porter cette ligne chez
les républicains peut-être pas avec
valérie pécresse je sais pas quelle
décision prendre à valérie pécresse en
tout cas valérie pécresse a été notre
candidate on est très fier d'avoir porté
sa candidature mais il ya des élections
législatives maintenant qu'ils nous
attendent et on continuera de nous
battre pour les républicains et avec les
républicains justement pour la suite le
score de valérie pécresse s'est pour
l'instant pour l'instant moins de 5% est
ce que vous craignez pour la survie du
parti écoutez je crois saisir votre
question mais je suis je suis pas
trésorier du parti donc que je ne sais
pas si si si oui ou non ça posera un
problème d'ordre financier puisque c'est
ce qui ce que vous entendez c'est que ça
ne déterminera l'avenir du parti mais je
crois que
les idées et courant comporte ce sera
plus fort que les difficultés
financières qu'on pourrait
potentiellement traverser ou même les
difficultés électorales on verra pour
les législatives on a des candidats qui
sont extrêmement implanté on a des
maires des conseillers régionaux des
conseillers départementaux et donc je
suis certain que aux législatives où on
trouvera la force de cette droite des
territoires d'accord pour l'instant on
ne sait pas quel courant va prendre le
dessus
chez l air une ligne plus dure une ligne
plus proche d'eux
de pécresse est ce que ça vous fait un
peu peur ce flou dans votre parti ça me
fait pas forcément peur dans la mesure
où les républicains c'est un parti de
droite mais qui vise à réunir toutes les
droites du moins toutes les sensibilités
de la droite républicaine donc ça a
toujours été comme ça ça a toujours
fonctionné depuis l'ump et donc il n'y a
pas de raison que ça ne fonctionne pas à
nouveau je pense que si on les si on
envoie un message d'unité ce qui sera je
suppose le cas demain lors du bureau
politique qui est organisée lundi matin
on saura se relever de cette épreuve et
qui aura pas d'éclatement à travers les
sensibilités du parti
merci beaucoup terence pour cette prise
de parole et voilà pour une prise de
parole de deux militants et l'air brunet
et vincent merci beaucoup mathis à
l'instant nathalie arthaud dernière donc
dans le classement de ce premier tour
des présidentielles de ses deux sauts
premier tour des élections
présidentielles renvoie dos-à-dos
emmanuel macron et marine le pen sans
donner de consigne de vote on signale
que mal mais on va peut-être vous coupez
mais rapidement avant jérôme sainte
marie patrick kanner qui vient
d'affirmer que le ps n'était sûrement
pas mort et olivier faur également appel
pour les législatives à une union des
forces de gauche est ce que c'est
possible alors c'est rendu davantage
possible qu'en 2017 par la position de
jean luc mélenchon en réalité la 2030
une fois la donner une consigne de vote
géré ce soir donc effectivement ces
déclarations seront destinés à négocier
pour avoir un groupe plus important l
année jean luc mélenchon avait regretté
d'alain peuvent finalement au fil des
temps de d'avoir eu cette ligne très
populiste le soir du premier tour 2010
est qui avait rendu impossible une
parole de hold up sur la gauche là
effectivement il se retrouve dans une
situation formidable pour pouvoir
négocier les circonscriptions avec les
autres formations de gauche est espéré
en récupérer quelques unes ça va être
très très difficile parce qu'on est bien
davantage à beaucoup de duels n'y aura
pas de triangulaire ce que la
participation sera très faible on va
avoir beaucoup de duels probablement
lrmr n cette fois ci à l'instant c'est
la cfdt
qui vient d'appeler à voter contre
marine le pen en précisant que ce n'est
pas un soutien à emmanuel macron une
réaction c'est évidemment un soutien
mais le maquereau on l'a fait david
était de toute façon comment dire à une
relation presque organique avec le
maquereau nisme et les députés qui sont
encore sont issus tous les fondations de
travailler main dans la main et
d'ailleurs par bien des côtés quand on y
rêve emmanuel macron est l'héritier à la
fois de michel crozier de michel rocard
de tout cela il ya une vraie continuité
idéologique et social pourtant pendant
tout ce quinquennat les relations ont
pas été forcément toujours au beau fixe
on reviendra sans doute avec marc landré
tout à l'heure entre entre la centrale
et mails macron
on à beaumont la réforme des retraites
oui on a beaucoup dit effectivement que
emmanuel macron avait vraiment court 6
court circuiter pendant tout son mandat
les corps intermédiaires
ceci dit quel est le poids aujourd'hui
du des corps intermédiaires dans
l'opinion quelle est la confiance que
les citoyens aujourd'hui accorde aux
corps intermédiaires
là aussi on peut se poser des questions
on parlait tout à l'heure de
recomposition du paysage politique moi
je dirais qu'on est vraiment dans le cas
d'une transformation plus globale du
paysage politique mais aussi du paysage
institutionnel classique c'est à dire
que ce sont plus les mêmes instances les
mêmes communautés aujourd'hui qu'on
écoute et dans lequel on a confiance
dans lesquelles les citoyen aujourd'hui
confiance donc que la cfdt en effet
appel à un vote
je ne suis pas sûr que ça fasse beaucoup
d'eux qu'ils aillent beaucoup d'impact
dans l'opinion aujourd'hui des français
jean françois copé veut que emmanuel
macron associe la droite au pacte de
gouvernemental c'est ce qui vient de
déclarer on devrait avoir d'une minute à
l'autre maintenant la déclaration d'
emmanuel macron qui vient d'arriver donc
oui tout à fait il vient d'arriver mais
n'est pas encore monté sur scène selon
notre notre équipe sur place vous voyez
donc ces images en direct évidemment des
kills démarrera son discours vous
pourrez le suivre en direct sur figaro
live on reviendra vers également dans le
qg donc de la numéro 2 de de cette
soirée marine le pen juste après
avoir entendu emmanuel macron peut-être
un commentaire et rémi leclerc notamment
à ce qu'on disait précédemment toujours
avec des données du sondage aujourd'hui
on voit qu'il ya finalement un front
républicain qui existent encore mais
plutôt dans la représentation donc ça va
être la cfdt ça va être certains
candidats et c'est chez les électeurs
c'est beaucoup moins flagrant que ça
quand on les interroge là aujourd'hui
dans le cas d'un second plus te
mangerais de vous donner une information
qui viennent de tomber puisque c'est une
estimation d'un autre institut mais qui
l'ifop qui donne donc premier sondage du
second tour et qui donne emmanuel macron
vainqueur 51 % mais c'est très serré
effectivement oui c'est toute façon il
ya une grosse incertitude sur ce second
tour rien n'est gagné rien n'est fait à
granby points de plus que pour un de
plein droit de 1000 points de moi pour
emmanuel macron que le sondage qui a été
réalisé et présenté hier en fait donc en
fait ça signifie que pour l'instant y'a
pas d'électrochoc lié à battre surtout
s'il a été réalisé après le
betty lise effectivement elle a dû être
fait avant fin mai entièrement raison
excusez moi est ce que ça pourrait
changer qu'est ce que ça change ça peut
changer les choses pour beaucoup
d'électeurs puisque quand on vous
interroge avant le résultat d'une
élection par exemple je suis un électeur
mélenchonistes je suis convaincu que mon
candidat va être second au second tour
je ne me projette pas encore dans un
second tour entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen pour une partie d'entre
eux donc je ne répond pas à la question
où je considère que c'est c'est un
scénario qui n'arrivera pas maintenant
ils sont dans une réalité et les
prochaines semaines alors il va se
passer encore beaucoup de choses la
campagne n'est pas fini il va y avoir un
débat d'entre deux tours on se rappelle
en 2017 que ça a été quand même un
moment clé de cette élection donc il
peut se passer encore beaucoup de choses
mais ce sondage réalisé avant l'annoncé
des résultats c'est pas ça n'a pas la
même valeur que les prochains sondages
qu'on aura dans les prochaines heures
les électeurs vont aussi pour certains
une petite partie d'entre eux de tenir
compte des consignes de vote
compte des réactions des candidats il ya
tout un tas de choses qui vont se jouer
dans cette soirée électorale et dans les
jours qui viennent qui peuvent influer
les résultats de cette élection de ce
second tour lors donc à priori ça
voudrait dire que emmanuel macron
pourrait progresser par rapport à ce
qu elle soit 51% tout à fait il pourrait
progresser mais j'ai envie dans les deux
sens marine le pen pourquoi pas pourrait
aussi progresser je pense qu'il ya aussi
une énorme inconnu qui et les
abstentionnistes du premier tour qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire parce qu'on en
oublie quand même ils sont importants
c'est absurde sans sioniste alors on est
aux alentours finalement maintenant de
26 % d'abstention c'est ça en terme
d'estimation que vont faire ces
abstentionnistes dans le profil des
abstentionnistes je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient des abstentionnistes
structurelles qu'ils s'abstiennent à
toutes les a toutes les 1 à toutes les
élections certains bons certainement se
mobiliser et on va voir aussi ce qu'ils
vont faire on va retourner dans le
quartier général
de
deux supporters s'étaient alors
retrouvés timothée des lames qui est
avec jean frédéric poisson
oui brunet version avec jean frédéric
poisson président du parti via la voix
du peuple bonjour jean frédéric poisson
merci bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous étiez l'un des premiers soutien
d'eric zemmour à l'automne à l'époque
qu'il avait une vraie dynamique dans les
sondages finalement il termine à 7 %
c'est une grosse déception pour vous on
imagine c'est une déception oui grosse
chebah si on peut la qualifier en tout
cas c'était certain c'est que quel que
soit le score
la candidature d'eric zemmour et seront
projet modifie profondément le paysage
politique français ce soir en terminant
devant la candidate des républicains
en étant le premier en dehors des trois
très gros candidats qui ont fait des
scores a non seulement à deux chiffres
mais autour de 20% et au delà eric
zemmour confirme que les thèmes qui l'a
porté pendant la campagne l'énergie le
courage la sincérité avec lesquels il
les a portés à parler aux français
malgré tout même si c'est un peu moins
que sensiblement moins que ce que nous
espérions en tout état de cause ces
thèmes se sont réintroduits dans paysage
politique la manière dont reconquête le
parti politique et ses alliés nous avec
lui ont occupé le terrain animé la
campagne remplit les salles parler aux
français tout cela ne sera pas sans
lendemain et même si ce soir le résultat
n'est pas conforme à nos espérances en
tout cas il ya quelque chose qui est
très porteur d'avenir pour le second
tour de la présidentielle puis pour la
suite les élections d'initiative et tout
le quinquennat le second tour tout
d'abord eric zemmour a appelé à voter
pour marine le pen est ce que c'est un
choix que vous soutenez oui absolument
en 2017 j'avais fait partie de ceux qui
n'avaient pas appelé à voter emmanuel
macron j'étais un des porte-parole de
françois fillon à l'époque et je n'avais
pas non plus appeler à voter marine le
pen parce que enfin pour des tas de
raisons qui ne sont plus d'actualité
aujourd'hui la différence cinq ans plus
tard c'est que nous savons ce qu
emmanuel macron nous voyons ce qu'il a
fait de la france nous voyons
l'accroissement de la pauvreté la
paupérisation des gens la précarisation
qui s'accélère aujourd'hui la mécanique
inflationnistes probablement peut-être
malheureusement des risques de pénurie
qu'on voit déjà sur les matières
premières demain peut-être sur un
certain nombre d'aliments enfin nous
sommes dans un état aujourd'hui cinq ans
après
l'élection d' emmanuel macron bien plus
grave bien plus dramatiques que ce que
nous connaissions il ya cinq ans je ne
parle même pas des questions de sécurité
la situation de l'islam conquérant et
d'autres sujets comme cela et je ne
parle pas non plus sinon pour les
évoquer rapidement de la pma samper de
la marchandisation de l'être humain et
d'autres choses comme celles là donc
nous savons ce que c'est emmanuel macron
nous connaissons son projet et nous ne
voulons absolument pas qu'il continue
donc même si c'est le cas d'eric zemmour
c'est la raison pour laquelle je les
rejoins nous n'avons pas nous avons
quelques différences avec madame le pen
il est impératif que monsieur macro ne
soit pas réélu président de la
république et donc que madame le pen
l'emportent dans quinze jours merci jean
frédéric poisson vous parler d' emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron qui justement
être en train d'arriver sur scène me dit
on brûle vincent je vous rends la parole
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est un compatriote
de métropole des outre mer et de
l'étranger
ce dimanche 10 avril
vous avez été plus de 36 millions à
faire valoir ce droit
[Applaudissements]
ce droit conquis par les générations
précédentes et le droit de vote
et je remercie tous nos compatriotes
y dès le premier tour ont porté leurs
suffrages sur ma candidature
leur confiance
votre confiance
mot normes obligent et m'engage
vous pouvez toutes et tous comptez sur
moi pour mettre en oeuvre ce projet de
progrès d'ouverture et d'indépendance
françaises et européennes que nous avons
défendu tout au long de cette campagne
je veux aussi
remercier
toutes celles et ceux
quelques-uns sont là ici ce soir à mes
côtés qui durant ces dernières années
ont tant donné
partout sur le territoire
vous avez donné votre énergie votre
travail vos jours et vos nuits je sais
ce que je vous dois merci
[Applaudissements]
non
et j'appelle tous ceux qui depuis 6 ans
et jusqu'à ce soir se sont engagés pour
travailler à mes côtés à transcender
leurs différences pour se rassembler en
un grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action pour notre pays
je veux saluer l'ensemble des candidats
présents au premier tour nathalie
arthaud
nicolas dupont aignan anne hidalgo
yannick jadot
jean lassalle
jean luc mélenchon
valérie pécresse
philippe poutou
fabien roussel
eric zemmour
merci à toutes et tous ce soir une fois
encore de les applaudir merci beaucoup
parce que depuis le début est depuis
toujours nous descendons des convictions
avec force mais en respectant chacune et
chacun merci pour cela
je sais
la déception des candidates et candidats
dont je viens ici d'évoquer le nom et
celle de leur soutien en de leurs
électeurs notre démocratie en effet
irish de tous les engagés qui défendent
leurs idées avec force et passion
merci à eux
je remercie anne hidalgo
yannick jadot valérie pécresse et fabien
roussel qui m'ont dès ce soir apporter
leur soutien
j'invite solennellement nos concitoyens
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
et quelques étés leur choix au premier
tour à nous rejoindre
certains le feront pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
je suis pleinement conscient que cela ne
vaudra pas soutien du projet que je
porte et je le respecte je sais que
c'est le choix fait par exemple par jean
luc mélenchon
mais je veux ici
saluer leur clarté à l'égard de
l'extrême droite et pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
mais dans ce moment décisif
pour l'avenir de la nation
plus rien ne doit être comme avant
c'est pourquoi je souhaite tendre la
main à tous ceux qui veulent travailler
pour la france je suis prêt à inventer
quelque chose de nouveau
on rassemblait les convictions et les
sensibilités diverses afin de bâtir avec
eux une action commune au service de
notre nation pour les années qui
viennent c'est notre devoir
à tous nos compatriotes
ils se sont tournés vers l'abstention
ou le vote extrême soit parce qu'ils
sont en colère face aux inégalités qui
persistent aux désordres écologiques à
l'insécurité du quotidien à la
difficulté de vivre dignement même quand
on travaille dur
soit parce qu'ils se sentent
insuffisamment représentés écoutez
associés je veux les convaincre
dans les jours à venir que notre projet
répond bien plus solidement que celui de
l'extrême droite à leurs peurs et aux
défis du temps quand tu es sur moi
car ne nous trompons pas
rien n'est joué et le débat que nous
aurons dans les quinze jours à venir est
décisif pour notre pays et pour l'europe
voulons nous d'une france indépendante
parce que forte sur le plan scientifique
technologique économique et militaire
agricoles et culturels
voulons nous d'une france qui parle
plein emploi et par le sérieux et
capables de financer son état providence
nos retraites notre école notre hôpital
et nos services publics
voulons nous d'une france qui relève le
défi climatique et écologique par le
nucléaire les énergies renouvelables la
sobriété énergétique et la planification
écologique
d'une france où par l'écologie les
factures de chauffage se réduiront et la
voiture électrique pour tous viendra
remplacer les coûteux plein d'essence
voulons nous d'une france plus juste
pour nos autres maires pour tout le
territoire pour notre est bien notre
hexagone voulons nous d'une france qui
face aux crises en cours et à venir
continuent à faire confiance à la
science à la raison à la compétence
comme nous l'avons fait ces derniers
mois et ces dernières années
[Musique]
je veux une france qui luttent
résolument contre le séparatisme
islamistes mais qui par la laïcité
permettent à chacun de croire ou de ne
pas croire
d'exercer son culte
et pas une france qui empêche les
musulmans ou les juifs de manger comme
le prescrit leur religion ce n'est pas
nous
je veux une france qui portent des
progrès pour chacun pour nos aînés pour
nos enfants pour les travailleurs pour
les familles pour les femmes et
notamment les mères seules pour les
précaires
pas une france de la régression pour
tous ce n'est pas nous
je veux une france qui s'inscrit dans
une europe forte continue de nouer des
alliances avec les grandes démocraties
pour se défendre pas d'une france qui
sortit de l'europe n'aurait pour seul
allié que l'international des populistes
et des xénophobes
ce n'est pas nous
je veux une france
fidèle
[Applaudissements]
je veux une france fidèle à l'humanisme
à l'esprit des lumières au souffle de
1789 tels sont mes chers compatriotes
mes chers amis les enjeux du 24 avril
ce sont les choix que par votre vote
vous aurez à faire dans 15 jours
je veux vous dire ce soir que je mettrai
toutes mes forces pour convaincre chacun
le seul projet pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet crédible contre la
vie chère c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet et travailleurs de
tous ceux qui sont au bord du chemin
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet de la france et de
l'europe c'est le nôtre
je croise en nous en nous tous quels que
soient nos parcours nos milieux nous
tous
quels que soient nos origines nos
territoires nous tous quels que soient
nos opinions et nos croyances nous tous
c'est cela la france
alors durant les quinze jours à venir
ne ménageons aucun effort car rien n'est
fait soyons humbles déterminé
allons convaincre chacune et chacun le
24 avril prochain nous pouvons faire le
choix d'une nouvelle époque française et
européenne le 24 avril nous pouvons
faire le choix de l'espoir le 24 avril
nous pouvons faire le choix de la france
et de l'europe ensemble
vive la république
et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron donc qui vient de
s'exprimer en chauffeur de salle en ce
moment encore sur la scène du parc des
expositions avant de partir peut-être
une analyse un commentaire par rapport à
la forme et par rapport au fond ma chère
l'or alors sur le fond il a vraiment
bros est très large il a parlé de
nombreuses thématiques que les français
ont envie d'entendre en tout cas sur
lequel il faudra qu'il y ait des débats
dans l'entre-deux tours et je crois que
la campagne d'entre deux tours va être
vraiment décisive pour le choix des
électeurs notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat il l'a rappelé à la fin de son
discours il a insisté sur cette priorité
des français il a également insisté
aussi sur l'environnement l'écologie et
puis l'union moi je dirai juste une
chose chat s'est étonnée par ces images
parce que je le trouve très seul
très seul il est assez magistrale assez
éloignée finalement de ces héros c'est
mon principe macron arrive donc voilà il
est il décent sur sa méthode de la scène
mais ce que je suis je suis assez étonné
quand on sait que son principal handicap
c'est la proximité avec les français
justement les électeurs français
aujourd'hui considèrent que c'est marine
le pen qui gagne le match de la
proximité avec les français et pas
emmanuel macron on va retourner tout de
suite dans le qg de marine le pen avant
de faire le point info avec maxime le
ricard daphné caravaca est avec un
militant daphné c'est à vous
oui merci brune bonsoir comment vous
appelez je m'appelle patrick et je suis
délégué départemental adjoint du
rassemblement national dans les
hauts-de-seine alors est ce que vous
étiez convaincu que marine le pen allait
gagner ce soir on n'est jamais
complètement sûr du résultat c'est les
français qui décide mais on avait quand
même une bonne option sur la victoire au
moins pour être en finale et là on est
en finale on est très content justement
pour le second tour est ce que vous
pensez que cette fois ci sera la bonne
évidemment ça va être la bonne on pense
que par rapport à 2010 est on a je pense
qu'on peut dire qu'on a plus de réserves
de votre mac rond et henry en fait les
français ont je pense en vie une bonne
fois pour toutes de se débarrasser de
maquereaux et pour toutes ces raisons je
pense que marine le pen a de très bonnes
chances de gagner la présidentielle dans
deux semaines justement avec l'appel au
vote de zemmour je trouve que c'est bien
sa part d'avoir invité ses électeurs à
voter pour marine le pen je trouve que
c'est élégant et c'est bien à part de
zemmour de l'avoir fait et justement
quelle quelle fourchette des lecteurs
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle va
réussir à convaincre maintenant dans
l'entre-deux tours je crois que oui
parce que maintenant le problème de du
second tour il va très simple ça va être
les patriots contre les mondialistes le
la candidat des patriots avec marine le
pen le candidat des mondialistes et
c'est macron donc les français vont
devoir choisir est ce qu ils veulent que
la france continue à être la france est
ce qu ils veulent que la france continue
à vivre où est ce qu'ils veulent que la
france devienne une province de l'union
européenne dans un ensemble mondialisée
à eux de choisir leur avenir moi le mien
j'ai choisi mon choix savez de voter
pour marine le pen merci beaucoup
merci merci daphné caravaca on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure mais tout de
suite c'est le point info avec maxime
laurie merci brune hui un nouveau point
juste après 22h et des scores qui ont un
petit peu évolué ces dernières minutes
d'abord votre confiance mot normes
obligent et mangas je viens de dire
emmanuel macron depuis son qg porte de
versailles les dernières estimations
ifop fiducial donnant le président
sortant toujours en tête de ce premier
tour bien évidemment avec 28 3% des voix
il n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de de
saluer les autres candidats perdants de
ce premier tour la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen
axel est elle aussi au second tour avec
23 3% des suffrages exprimés je n'ai ni
bonne mine ni envie d'être d'être d'être
réconforté je connais mon devoir la
lutte continue ce sont les mots de jean
luc mélenchon lui classé 3e de ce
scrutin avec 21,2 pour cent des voix
lors de son discours il a répété qu'il
ne fallait pas donner une voix à marine
le pen au 24 avril prochain le candidat
de reconquête eric zemmour obtient lui
7,2 pour cent des voix sur ses dernières
estimations il a appelé de son côté à
voter pour marine le pen suivent les
candidats placés sous les 5% les
colonies l'écologiste yannick jadot
d'abord qui est pour l'instant crédité à
4 8% et qui a d'ores et déjà appelé un
soutien financier pour couvrir ses frais
de campagne
un score égalité avec la candidate des
républicains valérie pécresse tous deux
ont également appelé à voter emmanuel
macron au second tour à la différence du
député des alpes maritimes eric ciotti
qui est aussi membre de la campagne de
valérie pécresse lui a promis qu'il ne
voterait pas pour le président sortant
le 24 avril vient ensuite jean lassalle
qui vient lui aussi de s'exprimer en
disant qu'il redevenait un simple
citoyen justifiant ainsi le fait qu'il
donnait pas de consigne de vote pour le
second tour le candidat du parti
résistons a obtenu 3,1 pour cent des
voix lors de ce premier tour suivent
enfin nicolas dupont aignan avec 1,9
pour cent là quand candidat de debout la
france a obtenu un résultat plus haut
que celui de la socialiste anne hidalgo
à 1,7 pour cent pour autant le ps n'est
sûrement pas mort a assuré le chef des
sénateurs socialistes patrick kanner
philippe poutou et nathalie arthaud
viennent enfin clore ce classement avec
respectivement 0,7 et 0,6 pour cent des
voix nathalie arthaud qui elle aussi n'a
pas donné de consigne de vote
merci merci beaucoup maxime l'aurait si
vous nous rejoignez nous sommes toujours
en direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre
page youtube figaro live pour décrypter
commentez et analysez les résultats de
ce premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle je me tourne je me tourne
vers vous et 1000 leclerc de doxa est ce
que on en sait un petit peu plus sur le
profil des électorats oui on en sait
même beaucoup plus sain c'est assez
classique alors danser un sondage qu'on
a réalisé aujourd'hui le jour du vote
donc on a demandé aux aux français pour
qu'ils avaient voté ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder les
électorats des deux finalistes
finalement celui des manies macron et
celui de marine le pen c'est très marqué
sur certains critères et notamment sur
l'âge c'est emmanuel macron vous avez 43
% des 65 ans et plus qui ont voté pour
lui je rappelle qu'en moyenne il est à
28 et demi en moyenne des différents
votes retraité très influent exactement
à votre traité très affirmée dans toutes
les autres classes d'âge il est aux
alentours des 20 des vins ou un petit
peu plus chez marine le pen en revanche
vous êtes après 30 % chez les la
catégorie finalement des actifs les 25
64 ans en moyenne c'est à peu près 30%
ce qu'est ce que ça signifie c'est que
si aujourd'hui les plus âgés ne votez
pas marine le pen serait largement en
tête il ya une raison assez forte à cela
on l'a vu récemment c'est la réforme des
retraites que souhaite mener emmanuel
macron depuis le début du quinquennat
les actifs sont majoritairement opposés
à cette réforme des retraites tandis que
les retraités eux ils sont favorables
aujourd'hui vous aider à la retraite il
ya aucun problème on passe la retraite à
65 ans ou plus si vous n'êtes pas à la
retraite vous y est opposée et ça c'est
un vrai sujet qui va sans doute faire le
second tour de cette élection si marine
le pen l'emportent au soir du second
tour ça sera probablement en partie
sur ce sujet des retraites qui va
cristalliser le vote jérôme quelle
stratégie devrait suivre marine le pen
sur quelles thématiques elle doit faire
campagne d'entre deux tours pour éviter
de connaître le même échec que en demies
en 2017 moi je n'en sais rien moi ce
n'est pas mon métier ça mais maintenant
j'en sais rien à ce que je sais
simplement c'est qu'effectivement parole
je me pose la question que vous avez une
sur quel sur quelles thématiques
elle pourrait elle pourrait capitaliser
parce que avec ce que vient de dire
émile
il ya quand même une forte mobilisation
de l'électorat retraités et toujours
historiquement et on voit pas comment
justement elle pourrait l'emporter avec
ce bar à le barrage justement ce soir et
il est très difficile de l'emporter
comme on irait il ya ya pas seulement
les retraités qui votent massivement
pour macron il ya aussi au sein des
actifs est-ce qu'on a peut appeler la
classe managériales c'est à dire les
cadres supérieurs et professions
intellectuelles de comment dirais-je du
public comme du privé dans le sondage
que j'ai vue dans l'enquêté réalisée
hier de farrou quelques jours de l'ifop
sur une base de 25 % d'intentions de
vote pour macron macro faisait 36 %
parmi les cadres encore une fois privés
et publics c'est donc voilà donc à
partir de là si vous voulez qu'on vous
reste deux semaines pour le second tour
forcément et vous avez une telle
polarisation sociale forcément il faut
assumer ce que l'on est hier foi assumée
effectivement d'être une certaine france
c'est à dire de constituer ce que j'ai
appelé moi un bloc populaire face au
bloc élitaire qui est là où n'avait tout
simplement pas le choix en réalité sauf
que ce bloc populaire et ne se réunir
élus pas à ses demandes loin de là tout
cas pour le bâtir il faut prendre les
demandes de l'opinion en général les
classes populaires en particulier non
seulement en termes de pouvoir d'achat
et de protection mais aussi bien entendu
est d'abord quand on s'appelle marine le
pen sur l'immigration la sécurité etc
non pas pour récupérer les quelques
l'électorat s'est réduit sommes tous
désormais de d'eric zemmour mais parce
que ce sont des demandes majoritaire les
deux tiers des français considèrent que
l'immigration est une mauvaise chose
pour la france à tous points de vue donc
à partir de là il a un thème sur lequel
le président sortant puisqu'il est
sortant et forcément faible et bien sûr
qu'il y aura ces deux thèmes la ses deux
jambes en quelque sorte de la campagne
qui seront activés probablement déjà
récupéré déjà une bonne partie des
électeurs qui étaient tentés par eric
zemmour est là dans notre enquête
d'aujourd'hui en ce qu on voit aussi
c'est que les deux tiers d'entre nous
disent je souhaite que eric zemmour
appel ce qu'il a fait un appel à voter
pour marine le pen n'ont probablement
ces derniers iront voter pour elle donc
c'est plutôt chez jean luc mélenchon que
ça va jouer est ce que les électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon et bien parvenir en
séduire certains est-ce qu'ils vont se
s'abstenir majoritairement est-ce qu'ils
vont se reporter sur les manuels macro
c'est là où ça va jouer dernière
question avant de changer de plateau
messieurs est
qui subit le roger le plus fort
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion qu'elle est
l'époux le pire épouvantail emmanuel
macron marine le pen marine le pen
encore aujourd'hui même si elle l'est
moins qu'auparavant c'est à dire que on
a une dans notre baromètre politique on
mesure chaque mois le la côte d'adhésion
et puis la cote de rejet c'est à dire
qu'on demande clairement français vous
rejetez cette personnalité politique
pendant longtemps marine le pen a été
parmi les personnalités les plus rejeter
et l'arrivée d'eric zemmour lui a permis
finalement de se normaliser et des deux
de paraître un peu moins comme un
épouvantail comme vous le dites pour de
nombreux électeurs mais elle reste
toujours plus rejeter que emmanuel
macron et la sphère mckinsey n'a pas du
tout joué sur la popularité de
d'emmanuel matin un petit peu dans notre
enquête on voit que certains électeurs
nous disent que où ils ont été choqués
je pense je reviens à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est plutôt sur une
thématique des retraites je pense que ça
davantage choqué des électeurs qui déjà
ne souhaitait pas voter pour une et même
emmanuel macron peut-être que ça en a
refroidi certains de gauche qui se sont
dits non finalement je vais me reporter
sur gmail en show notre candidat mais ça
a été
un critère clé pour beaucoup de lecteurs
alors emmanuel macron un handicap tout
simplement c'est le président sortant
c'est à dire qu'on lui adresse des
reproches parfois contradictoires
d'ailleurs sont les catégories qui
s'exprime et les sensibilités mais voilà
il est président sortant c'est pas
facile c'est comme pour ce qui est
arrivé à giscard d'estaing en 1981 on
fouille et en plus c'est un côté
répulsif 1 il a un côté répulsif aussi
et il a généré une détestation dans un
certain nombre de la population
française notamment dans le monde de la
france profonde en quelque sorte une
détestation qui est assez qui tient
d'ailleurs plus peut-être à son style à
ce qu'il incarne car son action à
proprement parler vous avez ensuite un
problème pour marine le pen c'est que
certes elle a beaucoup progressé dans
les sondages de popularité
elle fait partie très fréquemment les
deux ou trois personnes était le plus
apprécié cet ancien et gruissan et donc
tous l'objet maintenant va être pour les
mamans emmanuel macron de l'aria balisé
par contagion par capillarité en quelque
sorte en l'associant sans cesse à eric
zemmour c'est pour ça que le soutien
d'eric zemmour à marine le pen n'était
très probablement pas souhaité par celle
ci
cet internaute france europe soit 118 me
disais nous dit le débat du second tour
sera à cet égard décisif à ce que vous
êtes d'accord mais il a été en 2017
même s'il n'a pas été décisif l'a pas
changé des choses il a agrandi
probablement l'écart entre les deux
candidats il peut l'être évidemment
cette fois ci ce sera probablement plus
serré qu'en 2017 c'est quasi certain
vous verra dans quelle mesure je passe
sur ce débat soit si décisive dans la
mesure où toute façon importante marine
le pen est mieux préparé et puis comment
dirais-je son critère d'évaluation va
être le débat raté de 2010 est donc elle
est presque assuré va les respecter la
dernière fois et parce que n'oublions
jamais que le problème de marine le pen
en 2017 c'est son premier tour il 21% et
c'est la première fois d'ailleurs que
c'est aujourd'hui que elle a gagné des
voix en campagne alors que deux
campagnes précédentes elles en perdent
est très sensiblement et c'est après le
second tour a acté le fait qu'elle était
tout à fait minoritaire de je suis
entièrement d'accord avec me leclerc là
dessus le
débat n'a pas été décisif on estime
qu'elle a perdu 4 points à peu près
c'est à dire un million de 1 million 3
voix c'est considérable c'est un ratage
sont tous a laissé une profonde traces
dans son image nous on voit que ça n'a
pas été comment dirais-je ça ne n'a pas
été aussi le fatal que cela bloc contre
bloc c'est votre livre que vous avez
écrit vous théorisé justement sur ce
nouveau clivage c'est aux éditions du
cerf est également le bloc populaire qui
est votre dernier livre également aux
éditions du cerf on recommande bien sûr
la lecture de ces deux livres on
recommande également la lecture
attentive du dernier sondage de doxa
bakbone consulting qu'on va continuer
comme commenté justement le site du
figaro notamment avec gbagbo à partir de
maintenant merci beaucoup et mille merci
beaucoup merci a bientot et alors je lis
je lis toujours vos commentaires sur
youtube et jacob saint louis nous dit un
il y a deux lives comment on fait ça
c'est une transition parfaite pour vous
présenter notre second life qui qui a
démarré il ya maintenant treize minutes
se trouve également sur la page youtube
figaro live mais aussi sur facebook on
retrouve dont thibault gauthier et
adrien drian des réseaux sociaux vous
allez voir c'est un live servicielle qui
permet à chacun de savoir quels sont les
résultats danse dans sa commune dans
cette commune dans des vieux qui sont
chères
on cherche les résultats ici je salue
les internautes qui suivent cette grande
soirée avec vous brunet et vincent alors
c'est très simple ici vous nous demandez
sur les différents chat le nom de votre
commune adrien me les transmet et puis
on donne le résultat on essaye de
trouver tout alors on a cherché comme on
appelait les habitants d'haguenau les
haguenoviens les haguenovienne c'est en
alsace alors dites-moi adrien est ce qu
on a eu notre commune qu'on peut qu'on
peut chercher pour essayer de donner un
résultat alors nous avons senseo sur sur
facebook qui se serait noyé la veille
drame avec des airs avait eu l essai
dans le 91 draveil de senseo eh bien on
passe le bonjour à cnc va l'envoyer des
fois ça arrive on n'a pas le résultat
comme ici pas encore on attend vous
revenez un peu plus tard dans une petite
heure vous nous redemander le résultat à
draveil dans l'essonne est ce qu on fait
généralement quand on a parlé résultat
on essaye quand même de se renseigner
pour savoir quel avait été le score il y
à il ya cinq ans et il ya cinq ans et
emmanuel macron vous le voyez qui est
arrivé en tête avec 25 points 59 % des
voix devant jean-luc mélenchon et on
peut comparer on peut voir si ça a
évolué si les électeurs ont changé
d'avis ou ici ils sont restés dans la
même veine est-ce qu'on a une autre
commune alors on a un premier un premier
commentaire sur le sur le site du figaro
n'a pas encore pris de commentaires donc
on va vendre allons-y de pragma qui nous
demandent à les résultats pour me dont
meudon alors on le rappelle me dont tu
ne vas à ces grandes bas sûr qu'on est
les resultats exactement les plus grande
soit elle ont fermé plus tard pour les
vraiment les grosses villes les bureaux
de vote ont fermé aux alentours de 20
heures soit vers 19 heures les bureaux
de vote sont fermés mais il ya plus
d'habitants donc le dépouillement est
plus long mais tout à l'heure on a eu
les résultats wavre et wavre on s'est
rendu compte que jean luc mélenchon est
arrivé en tête alors que c'est la ville
où edouard philippe maire ce n'est pas
emmanuel macron qui a gagné au havre est
ce qu'on a le résultat à meuh non à
meudon toujours pas alors adrien
appliquez vous l'avez vous plaît parce
que parce qu on a les internautes de la
grande soirée qui nous suivent ils vont
se dire il ne trouve rien ces deux là
allez une petite ville avec gens
cherchent et nous avons kevin qui nous
demandent les résultats à maulévrier m à
huer le vert vr pardon hiver maulévrier
1,49 exactement maulévrier dans le maine
et loire exactement emmanuel macron
voyez qu'on peut trouver des résultats
assez largement en tête je pense que
c'est quasiment le meilleur score qu'on
a vu depuis le début dans une dans une
commune je sais pas une toute petite
commune vous le voyez
3190 habitants ici à maulévrier emmanuel
macron est donc en tête 8 111 voix assez
largement devant marine le pen petit
score jean luc mélenchon par rapport à
son niveau national et c'est yannick
jadot qui est devant valérie pécresse et
devant eric zemmour surtout faible score
pour lui à pour 7 pour cette commune de
maulévrier et c'est nathalie arthaud qui
en dernière position avec seulement
treize voix et lorsqu on peut voir aussi
sur les communes c'est l'abstention et
on a bien voté à un mollet vrai dans le
même les noirs parce que l'abstention
est à 21,36 plus bas qu'au niveau
national on remercie kevin kevin est ce
qui nous a pas déjà demandé kevin choix
qui les attendait une première a
effectivement on embrasse et qu'il
continue un parce que non bien l'aider à
trouver les résultats dans les communes
qui lui sont chers salle où il habite
celle de ses grands parents celle de sa
famille il vous donne vos résultats dans
la commune voilà donc vous pouvez
jongler à la fois sur le site du figaro
sur la page d'accueil bien entendu et
puis vous jonglez sur nos sur nos
réseaux sociaux entre facebook et
youtube on va être si vous continuez à
nous suivre sur youtube on va justement
retourner au quartier général de
emmanuel macron parc des expositions
porte de versailles retrouvez vincent
raison j'ai l'impression que vincent et
thé avec un militant et gagné
qui a suivi le discours des manuels au
maquereau qui vient de se terminer il ya
une quinzaine de minutes emmanuel macron
qui a fait ensuite un bain de foule
autour de la scène fort comment vous
allez trouver le discours du chef de
l'état candidat vient très clairement
voilà au vu de la configuration du
premier tour il fallait dans une logique
de rassemblement c'est ce qu'a fait ce
soir emmanuel macron donc c'était ce
qu'on attendait aussi voilà de notre
candidat d'un président candidat qui
porte un bilan bilan riche qu'il faut
faire connaître aux français mais aussi
un projet et je pense que le message clé
cas peu voulu faire passer manuel mâcon
ce soir c'est vraiment de se dire que ce
projet peut aussi répondre aux
inquiétudes des français même ceux qui
se sont tournés vers les extrêmes au
premier tour donc c'est clairement le
message qu'il va falloir qu'il va
falloir passer avant le second tour pour
justement faire le meilleur score